All right, here we go. Three hot mics, a good guest I'm thinking, I'm hoping. Sean, when was the last time you had three hot mics? That was like in my early 20s, my early 20s. Yeah, yeah. And by the way, it was confusing. We didn't know which end was it. I'm bad.
好了，我们开始吧。三个热麦克风，我想应该会有一位不错的嘉宾，我希望如此。肖恩，你上次用三个热麦克风是什么时候？那大概是我20出头的时候，20出头。对，对。顺便说一句，当时很混乱。我们都不知道哪一头是哪一头。我真糟糕。
None of them wanted to be called Michael. No, Mike, Mike, Mike. All right. And they were all equally hot? They were all equally hot. OK. Well, welcome to Smartless. Smart.
他们都不想被叫迈克尔。不，迈克，迈克，迈克。好吧。而且它们都一样热吗？它们都一样热。好的。那么，欢迎来到《Smartless》。Smart。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. That was fun that we got to see each other today. I know, just a half an hour ago.
Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。今天能见到面真开心。我知道，就在半小时前。
In person. Yeah, listen very rarely. Well, the three of us actually see each other in person before we start doing this. And we didn't we didn't we didn't expend any magic that that we would have left for the show. Yeah, we said we have to cry. No, the magic got stayed for sure. I gotta say Jason was not feeling well and he was on the other side of the table. It was big conference room and I got home. I got a little tickle on
面对面。是的，听着，真的很少见。我们三个在开始录制之前真的会面对面见到彼此。我们没有把任何留给节目的魔力消耗掉。是的，我们说我们必须得哭。不，魔力肯定留住了。我得说杰森当时感觉不太舒服，他坐在桌子的另一边。那是个很大的会议室，我回家时，喉咙有点痒。
my throat. You do not. I don't know. It's your head. Well, really. My virus has great reach on it. Did it? Well, I don't know. But Jay, that was so, like Wilson, that was so nice of you if you're feeling sick to go to the party on Saturday too. Yeah, that was nice of you. Well, but I didn't really feel it just yet.
你才没有。我不知道。那是你的心理作用。好吧，真的。我的病毒传播力很强。是吗？好吧，我不知道。但是杰，威尔逊，如果你感觉不舒服还要去参加周六的派对，那真是太好了。是的，你真好。好吧，但我当时还没什么感觉。
I wasn't really sure, you know. I would have never known you were in a good mood and lovely on Saturday. Just into this game. He did this game. Working. I was standing outside Sean, he did this game. Working. I was standing outside Sean, did you just left? We didn't see each other, but Jason came out
我不太确定，你知道的。我本来绝不会知道你周六心情很好，而且很可爱。只是玩这个游戏。他玩了这个游戏。工作。我当时站在外面，肖恩，他玩了这个游戏。工作。我当时站在外面，肖恩，你刚走吗？我们没见到彼此，但杰森出来了，
and he was holding two cupcakes. One was the big normal size one, one was the tiny baby one. Today, when we just left? No, no, no, the party on Saturday. And so he's got these cupcakes and he's doing a whole dance with it. And he's like eating the little one
他手里拿着两个纸杯蛋糕。一个是正常大小的，一个是超小的。今天，当我们刚离开的时候？不，不，不，是周六的派对。他拿着这些纸杯蛋糕，还跳了一段舞。他好像在吃那个小的，
and then somebody said to him, why did you have, well, I'm just gonna eat the little one, and I just got this one. So we continue to talk, and he put the big one, normal one down. And he eventually, well, he, first of all, I was like, if you've seen this before,
然后有人问他，你为什么要吃那个，好吧，我只是要吃那个小的，我刚拿了这个。所以我们继续聊天，他把那个大的、正常的放下了。他最终，好吧，他，首先，我就像，如果你以前见过这个，
and he took the top off, and he turned it upside down and ate it like a sandwich, so that you always get a nice invite. But then he put it down, and then this person said that, put it down, and then he put it a little further away. But then he put it down, and then this person said that, put it down, then he put it a little further away. And then he just went over and he walked it over to another table.
他把顶部取下来，翻过来像三明治一样吃掉，这样你总能吃到美味的糖霜。但后来他把它放下了，然后这个人说，把它放下，然后他把它放得远了一点。然后他把它放下了，然后这个人说，把它放下，然后他把它放得远了一点。然后他走过去，把它拿到了另一张桌子上。
Is that right, Jamie? Because you were like, it's too tempting close to you. You don't wanna have a grenade near you. Wait, I did not know that there was cupcakes there. Yeah, well, that was not the plot. That's why I don't know. Fuck me, man.
是这样吗，杰米？因为你当时说，它离你太近了，很诱人。你不想在身边放个手榴弹。等等，我不知道那里有纸杯蛋糕。是的，好吧，那不是重点。这就是为什么我不知道。去你的，伙计。
Well, first of all, you drifted over, you know, I gave everyone a very useful lesson as to how to eat a cupcake, which a lot of people don't know. I didn't know that. You twist off the top, you flip it over, you make it a sandwich, and then you don't get frosting up your nose.
好吧，首先，你飘了过去，你知道，我给了大家一个非常有用的吃纸杯蛋糕的课程，很多人都不知道。我不知道。你把顶部扭下来，翻过来，把它做成三明治，这样你就不会把糖霜弄到鼻子上。
That's A, B. The reason you don't know there were cupcakes there, Sean, is because you always do. Yeah. Very rudely. do. Very rudely. Very rudely. Because you're the first one at a party so that you can say you were there and that you can't get yelled at when you leave early because you've put in a bunch of time and you get your food and then you pack up your shit and you leave. It is true. It is true. Anyone who has shown us the amount of you. And I'm like, I wanna go home yet. Everybody does, man. I do wanna go. I want to go to a birthday cake that came out later
那是A，B。肖恩，你不知道那里有纸杯蛋糕的原因是你总是这样。是的。非常粗鲁地。做。非常粗鲁地。非常粗鲁地。因为你是派对上第一个到的人，这样你就可以说你来过了，当你早退时就不会被骂，因为你已经待了一段时间，拿了食物，然后收拾好你的东西就走了。这是真的。这是真的。任何展示过你这种行为的人。我当时想，我还不想回家。每个人都想，伙计。我想走。我想去参加后来才拿出来的生日蛋糕，
and some singing. So why did you leave? Why did you go in now? Why did you go at seven when it started and then leave so early? Me and Richard were there and Jenny were there. Richard and I. Tricky Dickie. Richard and I.
还有唱歌。那你为什么要走？你为什么现在才去？你为什么七点开始的时候去，然后又走得那么早？我和理查德在那里，珍妮也在那里。理查德和我。狡猾的迪基。理查德和我。
And first, and no, I enjoy going to those things. I was happy to go. I just, you know, I don't have a long fuse for parties. I'm the one with short fuse because I can't get into my cups like everyone else. And you start laughing at shit that doesn't deserve to be even smiled at. Did you have the chili?
首先，不，我喜欢参加那些活动。我很高兴去。我只是，你知道，我对派对的耐心有限。我是那个耐心有限的人，因为我不能像其他人一样喝得烂醉。然后你开始嘲笑那些根本不值得一笑的事情。你吃辣椒了吗？
I had the chili with me. Yeah, the chili. I had the chili at the time when everyone else had it. Not really. Where did you get the cupcakes? JB goes, JB goes to one point. Winston and Sadden and he goes, I gotta get out of here.
我当时吃了辣椒。是的，辣椒。大家吃的时候我也吃了。不完全是。你在哪拿的纸杯蛋糕？JB说，JB在某个时候说。温斯顿和萨登，他说，我得离开这儿了。
And he said, he's like, said like three times I said, where are you going? And he goes, I gotta gummy and a Lakers game to get into him. And that late at night on a Saturday. He was tape. You know, I mean, I type record again.
他说，他说了三次，我说，你要去哪？他说，我得去买软糖，还要赶上一场湖人队的比赛。周六晚上那么晚。他在录音。你知道，我的意思是，我再次录音。
Jason's beard and hair is growing so gloriously long. It's crazy. I know. It was the talk of the party. No. Yeah, it was. It looks good. What, how I can't really grow facial hair? No, you look good. No, it looks good like that. Yeah, shut up. It looks good. What do you see it in three more months when it looks really bad? No, thank you. No, I...
杰森的胡子和头发长得太茂盛了。太疯狂了。我知道。那是派对上的谈资。不。是的，确实。看起来不错。什么，我怎么就长不出胡子？不，你看起来不错。不，那样看起来不错。是的，闭嘴。看起来不错。你三个月后再看它，那时候看起来真的很糟糕？不，谢谢。不，我……
Well, not no, thank you, but also I doubt it. I think it looks really good. Whose guest is it today? It's my guest and guess what? What? You're gonna be real psyched. Hey, guest what? Guest what? Sean.
好吧，不是不，谢谢，但我对此表示怀疑。我觉得它看起来真的很好。今天是谁的嘉宾？是我的嘉宾，你猜怎么着？什么？你会非常兴奋的。嘿，猜怎么着？猜怎么着？肖恩。
Thank you. It's true, you guys are gonna be, you guys are gonna be, let us guess. We've never really really guessed. Okay, so male or female? No, guess. You ever wanted to be a big, like, you know what, you're gonna narrow it down by getting it.
谢谢。真的，你们会，你们会，让我们猜。我们从来没真正猜对过。好吧，男的还是女的？不，猜。你有没有想过成为一个大人物，你知道吗，你会通过猜测来缩小范围。
Five guesses to nail it down, but narrower. Male, okay. Actor. Yes. Older or younger than us? Younger, decidedly. Well, okay, decidedly, but yeah, more than two. This is a person who is a, America.
五个猜测来锁定，但范围更小。男的，好的。演员。是的。比我们大还是小？更年轻，毫无疑问。好吧，好的，毫无疑问，但多于两个。这是一个，美国人。
He has to get ready for this. His awards, his awards nominations has its own Wikipedia page. Really? And this is, okay, this is mostly film or television or music. Mostly film, some television back in the, but mostly film. I mean, two Academy Award nominations, two BAFTAs, four Emmys. Is this for some British? No, American, three globes, five sag award nominations, Tony Award nomination, critics choice up the wazoo, every critic. You're nervous now, God. You know what, here I'll give you a list of the names
他得为这个做准备。他的奖项，他的奖项提名有自己的维基百科页面。真的吗？这是电影、电视还是音乐？主要是电影，以前有一些电视，但主要是电影。我的意思是，两次奥斯卡提名，两次英国电影学院奖，四次艾美奖。这是英国人吗？不，美国人，三个金球奖，五个演员工会奖提名，托尼奖提名，影评人选择奖多得数不清，每个评论家。你现在紧张了，天哪。你知道吗，我给你列个名单，
of all the directors this guy's worked with. You ready for this? Tell me if you like any of these names. Ridley Scott, Terry. Terry Gilliam. Steven Soderbergh, Martin Scorsese Z. That's Russell. Who, JJ Abrams. Did I just guess it right?
这个家伙合作过的所有导演。准备好了吗？告诉我你是否喜欢这些名字。雷德利·斯科特，特里。特里·吉列姆。史蒂文·索德伯格，马丁·斯科塞斯。那是拉塞尔。谁，JJ·艾布拉姆斯。我刚才猜对了吗？
No, Noah Bomback. Adam Driver? Sean Levy. Yeah, it's Adam Driver. Did I get him? No way! I got Adam on out. That's my brother.
不，诺亚·鲍姆巴赫。亚当·德赖弗？肖恩·利维。是的，是亚当·德赖弗。我猜中了吗？不会吧！我猜中了亚当。那是我的兄弟。
That's my sweet brother. That's why I said you're gonna be saying. You guys know each other? Yeah. We worked on a project together. Adam, you were awesome on Sarenite Live. Oh, amazing. I just watched you do it.
那是我的好兄弟。这就是为什么我说你会很兴奋。你们认识吗？是的。我们一起合作过一个项目。亚当，你在《周六夜现场》表现太棒了。哦，太棒了。我刚看你表演。
Hey, show your recall. Thank you. It's terrible. The beat beat. Yeah, it's just like when you get a real actor in there doing Sarenite Live when you get a real actor in there doing Saturday Night Live, every sketch works, you know, this guy's making choices. Yeah, and I know that you didn't get a Saturday Night Live. I don't know, I think he's just
嘿，展示你的记忆力。谢谢。太糟糕了。节拍。是的，就像当你让一个真正的演员去演《周六夜现场》时，每一个小品都很有效，你知道，这家伙在做选择。是的，我知道你没上《周六夜现场》。我不知道，我想他只是
sensitive to the material and he's a funny dude, obviously. Well, I make a choice. It's a good choice. I've seen some good actors fucking bomb on SNL, let's be honest. Yeah, that's true. But he's just got Adam, you were so good, you were so funny. You're timing is so fucking good, dude. We are getting this episode, but all good. What about the piano playing? That seemed very weird. I know, I was blown away.
对剧本很敏感，而且他显然是个有趣的家伙。好吧，我做出了选择。这是一个好的选择。我见过一些好演员在《周六夜现场》搞砸了，说实话。是的，那是真的。但他就是有亚当，你太棒了，你太搞笑了。你的节奏感太好了，伙计。我们正在录这一集，但都很好。弹钢琴怎么样？那看起来很奇怪。我知道，我被震撼了。
Yeah, it was real. Is that you? Yeah, yeah. Yeah, that's amazing. Oh my God, I'd love to see a piano off between you. That's what that's a term, right? A piano off between you and Sean. I don't know if they use that. I'd lose. Yeah, that's amazing. Oh my God, I'd love to see a piano off between you. That's what that's a term, right? A piano off between you and Sean. I don't know if they use that. I'd lose.
是的，那是真的。那是你吗？是的，是的。是的，太神奇了。天哪，我很想看你们之间的钢琴对决。那是术语，对吧？你和肖恩之间的钢琴对决。我不知道他们是否用这个词。我会输的。是的，太神奇了。天哪，我很想看你们之间的钢琴对决。那是术语，对吧？你和肖恩之间的钢琴对决。我不知道他们是否用这个词。我会输的。
Yeah, that's a term. I lose. Adam, tell me about that. How long did you play piano? Did you study? Well, I played with, I played for, since I was a kid, but my mom tried to teach me, so it wasn't very, I didn't stick to it.
是的，那是术语。我会输的。亚当，告诉我那个。你弹钢琴多久了？你学过吗？好吧，我从小就弹，但我妈妈试图教我，所以不太好，我没坚持下来。
I feel like you're supposed to. You can cancel one, right? You're not, you're not supposed to, right? You're not supposed to have a parent teach you how to play piano because you never actually stick with it. Yeah. So that's true. That's why I dropped it.
我觉得你应该坚持。你可以取消一个，对吧？你不应该，对吧？你不应该让父母教你弹钢琴，因为你永远无法坚持下去。是的。所以那是真的。这就是我放弃的原因。
You said the, you know, my parents, my parents thought they were being real crafty when I said, I don't want to play. I hate, I hate practicing. You're going to practice. They would make me and you have the same material for a week, right? Because you have a, you have lessons once a week. And so they would say, you're going to, we're going to find out whether you're practicing or not, you're going to record your lesson or, right? Because you have lessons once a week. And so they would say, you're gonna find out whether you're practicing
你说，你知道，我父母，我父母以为他们很聪明，当我说，我不想弹。我讨厌，我讨厌练习。你要练习。他们会强迫我，你每周都有同样的材料，对吧？因为你每周上一次课。所以他们会说，我们要找出你是否在练习，你要录下你的课程，或者，对吧？因为你每周上一次课。所以他们会说，你要找出你是否在练习
or not you're gonna record your lesson, or sorry, you're gonna record your practice and we're gonna play it one week at home from work. And so I just record it once on the Monday and then just playing the same tape all week. And like they never figured it out. It was a lot of progress, really. I don't really know the Sunday, but yeah, but yeah, that was that
或者不，你要录下你的练习，我们会在工作之余的一周里播放它。所以我只是在周一录了一次，然后整周都在放同一盘磁带。他们从来没发现。真的进步很大。我不太了解周日，但是的，但是的，那就是
was it. They weren't bright, but they were strict. And you've always been such a fucking shit. Yeah, no, you've just a little shit since they were fucking bored. Not about me, though. Let's talk to Adam Adam driver, dude, dude, I'm so stoked to have you on here. I just, I just think you're so, you're just such a talent to dude. Everything you do is so fucking great. Thank you. Yeah, man. And then when I start to find out when I like looking back and, you know, looking about your sort of your background, I mean, you didn't, this seems to me and tell me it from wrong. You're from Southern California, right? Is that where you raised in Southern California? I raised in Indiana.
那样了。他们不聪明，但他们很严格。你一直是个混蛋。是的，不，你从小就是个混蛋，因为他们很无聊。不过不是关于我。让我们和亚当·德赖弗谈谈，伙计，伙计，我很高兴你能来这里。我只是，我只是觉得你太，你真是个天才，伙计。你做的一切都太棒了。谢谢。是的，伙计。然后当我开始发现，当我回顾，你知道，了解你的背景时，我的意思是，你没有，这对我来说似乎是，如果我错了请告诉我。你是南加州人，对吧？你是在南加州长大的吗？我在印第安纳州长大。
I lived in San Diego. Yeah, until I was seven. Okay, so until you were seven, you raised in Indiana. So you raised in Indiana, then 9-11 hits, you joined the military, right? You go into the Marines and I know you've talked about it before, but you go in, but it just seems like you had to kind of go a long way to get, but you knew what you wanted to do. Like you wanted to go to Julia Hard, the first time when you were seven, teen is that right?
我住在圣地亚哥。是的，直到我七岁。好的，所以直到七岁，你在印第安纳州长大。所以你在印第安纳州长大，然后9-11发生了，你加入了军队，对吧？你进入了海军陆战队，我知道你以前谈过这个，但你进去了，但看起来你为了达到目标走了很长的路，但你知道你想做什么。就像你想去朱莉亚德，第一次是在你十七岁的时候，对吧？
Yeah. And then you ended up going later, like walk me through, I just, what I'm sort of driving at is, you will get to time, you know, I swear. I'm fine, I could just listen to you guys. sort of driving at is you will get to time and I swear. No, he's getting ready. I'm fine, I could just listen to you guys. You're just a dude who is destined to do, like you knew what you wanted to do and it was fucking, you were just gonna get there
是的。然后你后来才去，带我走一遍，我只是，我想要表达的是，你会准时的，我发誓。我很好，我只是听你们说。想要表达的是你会准时的，我发誓。不，他准备好了。我很好，我只是听你们说。你只是一个注定要去做某事的家伙，就像你知道你想做什么，而且该死的，你只是会到达那里
no matter what. Kind of, I did plays in high school and then I auditioned for Juilliard because they didn't check grades. That was the prerogative of colleges that I was going to. And I knew that the Julia had had reputation of being the best of acting school for theater. And then I didn't get in. And then 9-11 happened. And I feel like a lot of people, a lot of friends in Indiana all thought they were going to join. But then none of them did. And then I was the only one
无论如何。差不多，我在高中演过戏，然后我试镜了朱莉亚德，因为他们不查成绩。那是我想去的大学的特权。我知道朱莉亚德有最好的戏剧表演学校的声誉。然后我没进去。然后9-11发生了。我觉得很多人，印第安纳州的很多朋友都以为他们会加入。但后来他们都没去。然后我是唯一一个
that did. Kind of like we all got riled up. And then I was the only one that did. Kind of like, we all got riled up. And then I was the only one that actually walked through the door. And then it was until I was in the military, really, that I'm like, oh, if I get, you know, if I get to be a civilian again, or when I get to be a civilian again, I knew I wanted to go back and try, try again to be a civilian again. I knew I wanted to go back and try again to be an actor. Was that a, was that a foreign question, by the way, how deep did you get into your military exploits? I loved it. The whole plan when I was in the military is to make a career of it. It was the retire, you know, in the Marine Corps. Oh, really? Yeah. And then it was only because I had a mountain biking accident.
做到的。就像我们都被激怒了。然后我是唯一一个做到的。就像，我们都被激怒了。然后我是唯一一个真正走进那扇门的人。直到我在军队里，我才真正想，哦，如果我能，你知道，如果我能再次成为平民，或者当我再次成为平民时，我知道我想回去尝试，再次尝试成为平民。我知道我想回去再次尝试成为一名演员。顺便问一下，这是一个外行的问题，你对你的军事经历了解有多深？我喜欢它。我在军队里的整个计划是把它作为一种职业。那是退休，你知道，在海军陆战队。哦，真的吗？是的。然后只是因为我发生了一次山地自行车事故。
I broke my sternum that I tried to train on it so I could still go overseas because all of the guys that I went to boot camp and then SOI then went into the fleet with, you know, it was all the same kind of core group of people. And then they were all going to go do a Westpac of Iraq and Afghanistan and again, I was kind of trying to train on a broken sternum so I could go go with them. And I got dropped to a different unit and all my friends went. And so I was not it was not good. Then 9-11 or you wanted to do it anyway? It was kind of twofold. It was a response to 9-11, but also I wasn't doing anything.
我摔断了胸骨，我试着训练它，这样我仍然可以去海外，因为我和我一起去新兵训练营的所有人，然后是SOI，然后进入舰队，你知道，都是同一群核心的人。然后他们都要去伊拉克和阿富汗的西太平洋，我再次试图在断了胸骨的情况下训练，这样我就可以和他们一起去。我被调到了另一个单位，我所有的朋友都去了。所以我当时，那不好。然后9-11或者你无论如何都想做？这有点双重。这是对9-11的回应，但也因为我什么都没做。
I was working jobs. I had two telemarketing jobs and I was working at a... I'd love to hear a little bit of that script. One was for a basement waterproofing company called Ben Franklin Construction. You probably... I don't... And then the other one was, uh... Are things smelling dank downstairs? Don't hang on. I, I used to have to read that same script for a different business.
我在打工。我有两份电话推销的工作，我在一家……我很想听听那个剧本。一个是为一家名为本·富兰克林建筑公司的地下室防水公司工作的。你可能……我不……然后另一个是，呃……楼下闻起来很潮湿吗？别挂断。我，我以前不得不为不同的企业读同样的剧本。
Really? For a different business. Sure, sure. I got no sleep noises. So, he was like, he was glad. But that, that was kind of it. And I, I, I got something in the mail and my stepdad, and I were having an argument about me being a loser and not having any jobs.
真的吗？为不同的企业。当然，当然。我没有睡眠噪音。所以，他很高兴。但那，那差不多就是那样。我，我收到了一些邮件，我的继父，我们正在争论我是一个失败者，没有任何工作。
And he kind of like, off-handedly said, maybe you should join the military. And again, it was in the same time of everyone kind of being like, well, we want to get involved and do something. So it kind of all kind of coalesced. And I think I made the decision by January and by February I was gone.
他有点随口说，也许你应该加入军队。同样，那是在每个人都觉得，好吧，我们想参与并做点什么的时候。所以它有点融合在一起了。我想我在一月份做出了决定，二月份我就走了。
So much so that they were like, are you on the run from the law? Because you've made people go, you're very eager, Mr. Driver. Wow, how's your relationship with your stepdad now? That's good. It's surprising. He's good.
以至于他们说，你在躲避法律吗？因为你让人觉得，你很渴望，德赖弗先生。哇，你现在和你继父的关系怎么样？很好。很令人惊讶。他很好。
Yeah, is he proud of you? Yeah. I guess you won the question of whether or not you were a loser. You got to, you over it. Not only am I going to join the military, but I'm going to go through Booth, can I become a Marine, and then I'm going to kick ass in the completely opposite end of the world as well. Yeah, and become a fucking movie star.
是的，他为你骄傲吗？是的。我想你赢得了关于你是否是失败者的问题。你克服了它。我不仅要加入军队，我还要通过新兵训练营成为一名海军陆战队队员，然后我还要在世界的另一端大显身手。是的，还要成为一个该死的电影明星。
I mean, it's pretty remarkable. So you come back from serving, you leave the military, or you get discharged, as you said, and then you're like, what, back at square one, you're like, how do you climb the mountain that you've climbed? Like, what was... You reapplied at Juilliard, yeah. I reapplied at Juilliard. Actually, I should say before I left for the military,
我的意思是，这非常了不起。所以你服役回来，你离开军队，或者你像你说的那样退伍了，然后你就像，什么，回到原点，你就像，你是怎么爬上你爬过的那座山的？就像，什么是……你重新申请了朱莉亚德，是的。我重新申请了朱莉亚德。其实，我应该说在我去军队之前，
I tried coming to LA and doing the whole acting thing. And I totally failed. I had a Lincoln town car, and I was paying rent in the back of my parent's house. And I loaded up this massive car, and I drove across country to California, and I broke down in Amarillo, Texas, and wound up spending all my money fixing my car.
我试着来到洛杉矶，做整个表演的事情。我彻底失败了。我有一辆林肯城市车，我在父母房子的后面付房租。我装满了这辆巨大的车，我开车横穿全国来到加利福尼亚，我在德克萨斯州的阿马里洛抛锚了，最后把所有的钱都花在修理车上了。
So by the time I got to Santa Monica, not even LA, I was here for 48 hours before I turned right and drive right back. He wasn't having any more money. I had no money to stay. I drove out to Chicago and my car broke down in Colorado, like around a mountain, and I was dragging the muffler for the last part. And I had a pullover, it cost me a thousand bucks, but I made it.
所以当我到达圣莫尼卡时，甚至不是洛杉矶，我在这里待了48小时，然后我就掉头开车回去了。他没钱了。我没钱留下来。我开车去芝加哥，我的车在科罗拉多抛锚了，就在山附近，最后一段路我拖着消音器。我有一件套头衫，花了我一千块，但我成功了。
Oh, really? Yeah, same. I looked at my car, it was outside of Amarillo, Texas, and I got a hitch to ride into town, and then took my car and got a fix. But that was all my money. I had just 200 bucks left, which I knew from having just made the trip was enough gas money to get home.
哦，真的吗？是的，一样。我看着我的车，它在德克萨斯州阿马里洛外面，我搭便车进城，然后把我的车修好了。但那是我所有的钱。我只剩下200块了，我知道从刚才的旅行来看，那是足够回家的油钱。
And I made a whole production about saying goodbye to everybody back in New York. Sure. Then 40 out of your back. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I can't believe that. But you know, Adam, a lot of people would, after an experience like that,
我做了一整套告别仪式，和纽约的每个人告别。当然。然后40岁就回来了。是的，是的，是的。我不敢相信。但你知道，亚当，很多人在经历那样的事情之后，
which is, I mean, that's not traumatizing, but it's a lot. Like you go through, you make the, like you said, you make a big production out of, I'll see you guys later, you give your farewell to the troupe, as it were, and then a week later, you're back or less.
我的意思是，那不是创伤，但那很多。就像你经历的，你做到了，就像你说的，你做了一场盛大的告别，我会再见到你们的，你向剧团告别，然后一周后，你又回来了，或者更短。
And then you go, and then you go into the military. A lot of people would be like, you know what? The universe was trying to tell me something, or it's, it's a lot to pick yourself up again and to go, no, I wanna fucking do this. This is kinda what I'm getting out of the beginning, which is like, you're just like, no, you're determined. You knew that you had a purpose in this world, especially doing this.
然后你去，然后你进入了军队。很多人会说，你知道吗？宇宙在试图告诉我什么，或者，重新振作起来，说，不，我他妈的想做这个，这很难。这有点像我从一开始就得到的，就像，你只是，不，你很坚定。你知道你在这个世界上有一个目标，特别是在做这个的时候。
Not really. No, I still didn't want to. The idea of being an actor was like being an astronaut. I had no connections to anybody in the acting world and in the small town in Indiana. So I just kind of put that idea to bed. I still liked movies. to anybody in the acting world and in the small town in Indiana. So I just kind of put that idea to bed. I still liked movies. But I just kind of gave up on that.
不完全是。不，我还是不想。成为一名演员的想法就像成为一名宇航员。我在印第安纳州的小镇上与演艺界的任何人都没有联系。所以我只是把那个想法搁置了。我还是喜欢电影。与演艺界的任何人都没有联系。所以我只是把那个想法搁置了。我还是喜欢电影。但我只是放弃了那个想法。
And then when the Marine Corps came along, I fully threw myself at that. And it was only during the military where I felt like, well, in comparison to the Marine Corps civilian life, I think, should be pretty easy. I knew that New York was kind of what I wanted to do if I ever got out and having, you know, I could sleep in the Central Park. I felt more confident that I could be an adult and survive. How did you know you were any good at acting? I found in high school the response I got from people was positive, you know, but it's an high school in Indiana. I didn't really know until I auditioned for
然后当海军陆战队出现时，我全身心地投入其中。只有在军队里，我才觉得，好吧，与海军陆战队的平民生活相比，我想，应该很容易。我知道如果我退伍，纽约是我想要去的地方，而且，你知道，我可以睡在中央公园。我觉得更有信心，我可以成为一个成年人并生存下去。你怎么知道你擅长表演？我在高中发现人们给我的反应是积极的，你知道，但那是在印第安纳州的一所高中。我直到第二次试镜朱莉亚德才真正知道，
Juilliard the second time and I got out. So, right, so how did that happen? So you get out of the military, how do you auditioned the second time? Like, what was that process like? So, I got out and I went to a school called University of Indianapolis and then I start getting parts and plays right away. And I knew that the audition date for Juilliard was they had three days, four days in New York, they don't do this now, but they do four days in New York, four days in Chicago and four days in LA. And I knew they were auditioning in Chicago in February, so I drove up and I stayed the night and I auditioned in Chicago. And then, yeah, then I found out I
我进去了。所以，对，那是怎么发生的？所以你退伍了，你是怎么第二次试镜的？就像，那个过程是什么样的？所以，我退伍了，我去了印第安纳波利斯大学，然后我立刻开始在戏里得到角色。我知道朱莉亚德的试镜日期是，他们在纽约有三天，四天，他们现在不这样做，但他们在纽约有四天，芝加哥有四天，洛杉矶有四天。我知道他们二月份在芝加哥试镜，所以我开车上去，住了一晚，我在芝加哥试镜了。然后，是的，然后我发现我
got in like a two months, two months later. Did you find like, did you enjoy your time in the Marine Court and why you were there? Were you thinking about acting the whole time? No, I enjoyed it until a point. And then I really, because I was on the verge of being separated, all my guys kind of left of left, that I, you know, they're like, okay, then maybe I shouldn't, this, I'm not long for this.
两个月后进去了。你觉得，你享受在海军陆战队的时间吗？当你还在那里的时候？你在整个过程中都在想表演吗？不，我享受它直到某个点。然后我真的，因为我处于被分离的边缘，我所有的伙计都离开了，我，你知道，他们就像，好吧，那也许我不应该，这个，我不适合这个。
Yeah, that's weird, because the whole time Sean's acting, he's thinking about Marines. So listen. I can get in Yang thing. I mean, I got it, I get it, Adam. So you can, so you see, you go fucking Chicago, it blows me away, man. I get it. So you come, so you see, go fucking Chicago.
是的，这很奇怪，因为肖恩一直在表演，他一直在想海军陆战队。所以听着。我可以进入杨的事情。我的意思是，我明白了，我明白了，亚当。所以你可以，所以你看，去他妈的芝加哥，这让我大吃一惊，伙计。我明白了。所以你来，所以你看，去他妈的芝加哥。
It blows me away, man. I just, it's just like, not long shot because you're down, I was in mega town to do, but you go in your audition and then two months later you find out, it's your fucking dream. What's your reaction when you find out you're getting to Juilliard? Like, yeah, it was beyond.
这让我大吃一惊，伙计。我只是，这就像，不是长镜头，因为你倒下了，我在大城市做，但你去试镜，然后两个月后你发现，这是你他妈的梦想。当你发现你要去朱莉亚德时，你的反应是什么？就像，是的，那超出了。
I was working full-time at a Target distribution warehouse and going to school full-time at University of Indianapolis, so it was kind of pulling all nighters and then going to school full-time. So I was beyond, you know, you're like screaming all the... It must have felt like getting like this is your chance, you're going to get pulled into this out of your world and into this other world that you've been trying to get into and you've been dreaming of. This is about to happen, it must have felt like that.
我在塔吉特配送仓库全职工作，同时在印第安纳波利斯大学全职上学，所以有点通宵达旦，然后全职上学。所以我超出了，你知道，你就像在尖叫所有……那一定感觉像是得到，就像这是你的机会，你会被从你的世界拉出来，进入这个你一直试图进入并一直梦想的另一个世界。这就要发生了，一定感觉是那样。
But I wasn't even thinking of like, oh, now I'm gonna be an actor and plays or now I'm gonna be in film. So just the idea of going to New York was another. And the alumni of Juilliard, I was very aware of, And the alumni of Juilliard, I was very aware of. And how it's a conservatory and it was a great place to put a lot of energy. You know, it was in the early 20s.
但我甚至没想过，哦，现在我要成为一名演员，演戏，或者现在我要拍电影。所以仅仅是去纽约的想法就是另一个。而且朱莉亚德的校友，我非常清楚，而且朱莉亚德的校友，我非常清楚。而且它是一个音乐学院，是一个投入大量精力的好地方。你知道，那是在20出头的时候。
So. Did you have a good idea of what, what, what, I mean, obviously you got a very good idea of what it would be like to live in New York. We all see it in TV and movies and whatnot. But Juilliard itself, did you have a pretty decent idea of what that experience was going to be like and if so, did it match with that idea? Once you got that. No frame of reference for what living in New York would be, well, other than films that,
所以。你对，你对，我的意思是，显然你对在纽约生活会是什么样子有一个很好的想法。我们都在电视和电影里看到了。但朱莉亚德本身，你对那种经历会是什么样子有一个相当不错的想法吗？如果是这样，它符合那个想法吗？一旦你得到了那个。对在纽约生活是什么样子没有参考框架，好吧，除了电影，
but no frame of reference of like an acting conservatory. A lot of the kids in my class were four years younger than I was and kind of had gone to performing arts schools or they were there for their graduate degree. They don't do this anymore. Even if you went to an undergrad program, you would get your diploma, but now it's a graduate program also. But so people had come from performing arts backgrounds.
但对表演音乐学院没有参考框架。我班上的很多孩子比我小四岁，而且有点上过表演艺术学校，或者他们是为了研究生学位在那里。他们现在不这样做了。即使你上了本科课程，你也会拿到文凭，但现在它也是一个研究生课程。但所以人们来自表演艺术背景。
And I didn't. So when I moved to the city, like summer before I started, and we'll go to the performing arts library and try to read plays that everybody knew that I didn't know, like a Tony Kushner plays. That's so cool. David Mamma plays, and I've watched the performances and the video library to get Lincoln at Lincoln Center. Yeah, yeah, that's so cool. You know, I know you did burn this in 2019. Yeah, yeah. I did that in college, of course.
而我没有。所以当我搬到这个城市时，就像我开始之前的夏天，我们会去表演艺术图书馆，试着读每个人都知道但我不知道的剧本，比如托尼·库什纳的剧本。太酷了。大卫·马梅的剧本，我看了林肯中心林肯表演的视频库。是的，是的，太酷了。你知道，我知道你在2019年演过《Burn This》。是的，是的。我当然在大学里演过那个。
I played Larry. He played Payal, of course. We would have been a brilliant match to him. You would have been great. But a friend of mine was in the play. And they didn't, and on the huge marquee downtown LA, he did burn this. And they didn't separate the letter.
我演了拉里。他当然演了佩尔。我们会是一个绝配。你会很棒的。但我有个朋友在戏里。他们没有，在洛杉矶市中心巨大的广告牌上，他演了《Burn This》。他们没有把字母分开。
So it looked like burnt his. And so that's that's what we referred to. That's LA Theater for you. That's LA Theater. Yeah. And we will be right back. Thank you to FanDuel for supporting this episode of SmartLess. The NFL regular season is wrapping up, but there's still time to get in on the action
所以看起来像“Burnt His”。所以这就是我们指的。这就是洛杉矶戏剧。这就是洛杉矶戏剧。是的。我们马上回来。感谢FanDuel支持这一集的《SmartLess》。NFL常规赛即将结束，但还有时间参与其中
with FanDuel, America's number one sports book. Right now, new customers get 150 in bonus bets guaranteed when you place a $5 bet. That's 150 bucks in bonus bets, win or lose. The app is so easy to use and there are so many different ways to bet, like live same game parlays, find bets in the new Explore tab, make a parlay in the parlay hub, the best way to find popular parlays and more. You know what'd be fun to bet on? How many pigs in a blanket I can eat in, like, say, 30 minutes?
与FanDuel，美国第一体育博彩公司。现在，新客户在下注5美元时，保证获得150美元的奖金投注。那是150美元的奖金投注，无论输赢。该应用程序非常易于使用，并且有许多不同的投注方式，例如现场同场连赢，在新的探索选项卡中查找投注，在连赢中心进行连赢，这是查找热门连赢等的最佳方式。你知道赌什么会很有趣吗？我可以在，比如，30分钟内吃多少个猪肉卷？
Who's in for that? Who would bet on that? I'd probably throw up after three, but maybe more, but that's what you'd be betting on. So visit fandool.com slash smartless and make your first bet a layup, fandool, official partner of the NFL, 21 plus exclusions apply,
谁想参加？谁会赌那个？我可能吃三个后就会吐，但也许更多，但这就是你要赌的。所以访问fandool.com/smartless，让你的第一次投注成为上篮，FanDuel，NFL官方合作伙伴，21岁以上，适用排除条款，
see show notes for Full Disclaimer. Thank you NBC for supporting this episode of The Show. Hey, happy new year everyone, and I've got a resolution for you. Laugh more. Good one, right? And to that end, I give you two hilarious comedies, starring two legendary Johns, John Lerocat in the new season of Nightcourt and John Cryer in his new comedy Extended Family. Tuesday nights and NBC, the laps are never in short order.
查看节目说明以获取完整免责声明。感谢NBC支持这一集的节目。嘿，新年快乐，大家，我有一个决议给你们。多笑。好主意，对吧？为此，我给你们两部搞笑喜剧，由两位传奇约翰主演，约翰·拉罗奎特在《夜间法庭》新一季中，约翰·克莱尔在他的新喜剧《大家庭》中。周二晚上在NBC，笑声从不短缺。
When New York's most outrageous court gets back in session, it's America's number one comedy Nightcourt, starring John Lerocat. And after that, catch John Cryer in a great new comedy about life and family after divorce, its Extended Family. Also starring the amazing Donald Fazon and Abigail Spencer. New Year's resolution, laugh more in 2024,
当纽约最离谱的法庭重新开庭时，它是美国第一喜剧《夜间法庭》，由约翰·拉罗奎特主演。在那之后，观看约翰·克莱尔在一部关于离婚后生活和家庭的精彩新喜剧《大家庭》中。还由出色的唐纳德·法森和阿比盖尔·斯宾塞主演。新年决议，2024年多笑，
with help from two fantastic comedies, Nightcourt and extended family, starring John Lerocat and John Cryer. Tuesday's an NBC beginning January 2nd. ["The New Year's Day"] Hey, Smartless Crew, I've been drinking A.G.1 since 2020. It's become my daily go-to foundational nutrition, supplemented, it's true.
在两部精彩喜剧《夜间法庭》和《大家庭》的帮助下，由约翰·拉罗奎特和约翰·克莱尔主演。周二在NBC，1月2日开始。["新年快乐"] 嘿，Smartless团队，我从2020年开始喝AG1。它已经成为我日常的基础营养补充，是真的。
I trust AG1 because it's not just about what's in it, but what's not in it. AG1 is rigorously tested for 950 impurities way beyond the industry norm. Seriously, it's a game changer for me. I feel the difference daily. I have improved energy. It's so convenient.
我信任AG1，因为它不仅在于里面有什么，还在于里面没有什么。AG1经过严格测试，排除了950种杂质，远超行业标准。说真的，这对我来说是一个游戏规则的改变者。我每天都能感觉到不同。我的能量提高了。它太方便了。
I love the convenience of it. And I can do it at home or I can take the travel packs which is super convenient, you know, if I'm on the road. Now, let's get into the good stuff. Why AG1? It's a powerhouse for major body systems
我喜欢它的便利性。我可以在家里喝，也可以带旅行装，这非常方便，你知道，如果我在路上。现在，让我们进入好东西。为什么选择AG1？它是主要身体系统的动力源
with ingredients like vitamin C and zinc, which helps me keep my immune health in tip-top shape. And everybody at SmartList loves it too. They drink it religiously. AG1 is the supplement I trust to provide the support my body needs daily, and that's why they've been a partner for so long.
含有维生素C和锌等成分，这有助于我保持免疫健康处于最佳状态。SmartList的每个人也都喜欢它。他们虔诚地喝它。AG1是我信任的补充剂，能提供我身体每天所需的支撑，这就是为什么他们合作了这么久。
If you take just one thing, let it be AG1. Try AG1 and get a free one-year supply of vitamin D3K2 and 5 free AG1 travel packs with your first purchase. Go to drinkag1.com slash smartless so they know we sent you. That's drinkag1.com slash smartless. Check it out. So they know we sent you. That's drinkag1.com slash smartless. Check it out. All right, back to the show.
如果你只选一样东西，那就让它成为AG1。尝试AG1，并在首次购买时获得一年的维生素D3K2和5个免费的AG1旅行装。前往drinkag1.com/smartless，这样他们就知道是我们派你来的。那是drinkag1.com/smartless。去看看吧。这样他们就知道是我们派你来的。那是drinkag1.com/smartless。去看看吧。好了，回到节目。
Now Adam, I don't, I've never met you in a huge fan. I'm like, trying to get the bit to ask you about Star Wars, which I'm sure you're sick of talking about. Cool it. But I know I'm a click. But I'm a huge fan. So we apologize. But you do seem like not knowing you at all. You seem to be a very kind, sweet, down to earth,
现在亚当，我，我从来没见过你，我是个超级粉丝。我像，试图找个机会问你关于《星球大战》的事，我肯定你已经厌倦谈论它了。冷静点。但我知道我是一个点击。但我是一个超级粉丝。所以我们道歉。但你看起来，完全不认识你。你看起来是一个非常善良、甜美、脚踏实地、
intelligent, yet introverted person. And so what is it like doing something like Saturday Night Live, which is the opposite of being introverted? And it's just going balls out. Like, is it scary? And is that why you wanted to do it? Or is it just another job?
聪明，但内向的人。那么做像《周六夜现场》这样的事情是什么感觉，这与内向相反？而且只是全力以赴。就像，这很可怕吗？这就是你想做它的原因吗？还是这只是另一份工作？
I don't know why, it's kind of theater, I mean, in a way. So that's what I at least try to remind my, but it's terrifying. Yeah, it is. But I enjoy the, I would feel like theater on film. I like those old school plays on tape that they used to do live, Richard Burton, you know, doing Camelot.
我不知道为什么，这有点像戏剧，我的意思是，在某种程度上。所以这至少是我试图提醒我的，但这很可怕。是的，确实。但我享受，我会觉得电影上的戏剧。我喜欢那些他们过去现场表演的旧式磁带戏剧，理查德·伯顿，你知道，表演《卡米洛特》。
And that's the only modern day equivalent of a show that does that. And I really enjoy the pressure. I don't know. It's a massive, but I'm also in my best behavior and things like this and in public. The real ego maniacal asshole is just waiting to come out all the time. We can't wait to meet him. Yeah, and a few weeks to hear that. There's no place.
那是唯一现代的、做那种表演的节目。我真的很享受压力。我不知道。这是一个巨大的，但我也是在公共场合表现得最好，像这样。真正的自我狂妄的混蛋一直在等着出来。我们迫不及待地想见到他。是的，几周后听到那个。没有地方。
You did, you did, you did seem beautifully relaxed. Yeah, well, I mean, there was an energy there for sure, but you certainly weren't terrified. It was pretty cool. Yeah, the last, I mean, the first time I did it, I thought I was gonna pass out when you walk out. But this time, I felt at ease. And I enjoy the pressure and I like it when there's a lot to do. You know, when the pressure's on,
你确实，你确实，你确实看起来非常放松。是的，好吧，我的意思是，那里肯定有一种能量，但你肯定没有被吓坏。这很酷。是的，最后，我的意思是，我第一次做的时候，我以为我走出来时会晕倒。但这次，我感到很自在。我享受压力，我喜欢有很多事情要做的时候。你知道，当压力来临时，
and there's a lot of text and a lot of moving pieces and a lot of things falling apart, I actually kind of enjoy it. It reminds me of theater. I noticed you're not really reading the cards that much either. Did you try to commit certain lines to notice that? Yeah, I noticed that. So you could perform them well. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, because I don't like it usually when you can kind of tell that someone's reading
有很多文字，有很多移动的部分，有很多事情分崩离析，我实际上有点享受它。这让我想起了戏剧。我注意到你也没有怎么看卡片。你试着记住某些台词吗？是的，我注意到了。这样你就能表演得很好。是的，是的，是的。是的，因为我不喜欢通常当你能看出有人在读
the cards and it kind of destroys the illusion. And when they're well written, it's easy to memorize. So some of it is, it's not that difficult. They hate it when you don't read the cards and it kind of destroys the illusion. And when they're well written, it's easy to memorize. So some of it is, it's not that difficult. They hate it when you don't read the cards though. Yeah, they're nervous. Is there one sketch that you particularly loved doing last time? There's one that I really liked that was cut. It was this one called court case. And it was this three-page speech that's not funny at all. And it only works if it's played as if it's absolutely serious. And we cut it. But then they released it online afterwards.
卡片时，它有点破坏了幻觉。当它们写得好时，很容易记住。所以其中一些，并不那么困难。他们讨厌你不读卡片，它有点破坏了幻觉。当它们写得好时，很容易记住。所以其中一些，并不那么困难。他们讨厌你不读卡片。是的，他们很紧张。有没有一个你上次特别喜欢做的小品？有一个我真的很喜欢但被剪掉了。有一个叫“法庭案件”的。这是一个三页的演讲，一点也不好笑。只有当它被表演得好像绝对严肃时才有效。我们剪掉了它。但后来他们事后在网上发布了。
But I love that at the dress, everyone. I love the dead air and how awkward it was in the office. I love the... Are they doing that now? Are they putting the dress? Leasing cuts, the dress? Yeah, or some of it? Some of it. I love that. Are they doing that now? Are they are they releasing cuts sketch address? Yeah, some of it. Some of it. They that's cool with those. They they was two of them that they released this like court case one
但我喜欢在彩排时，每个人。我喜欢那种死寂和办公室里的尴尬。我喜欢……他们现在在做那个吗？他们在放彩排吗？剪辑，彩排？是的，或者其中一些？其中一些。我喜欢那个。他们现在在做那个吗？他们是在发布彩排小品吗？是的，其中一些。其中一些。他们，那很酷，那些。他们，他们有两个他们发布的，像这个法庭案件的。
and this one called actors journey. Because Tracy dresses short for dress. That's such a cool. That's a cool idea. Yeah. So right for Tracy, let her know that at they do dress rehearsal earlier on the on Saturday night, full. It's like a full performance of the show with some additional sketches and they cut a couple sketches before the live show.
还有这个叫《演员之旅》。因为特蕾西（Tracy）为彩排准备的时间很短。这真是个很酷的想法。是的。所以，告诉特蕾西，让他们知道周六晚上会进行完整的彩排。这就像是演出的完整版，还会增加一些小品，然后在直播前会删掉几个小品。
Dress usually is over by about 10, 10, 30. And then the live show is 11, 30. But I think that's cool because there have been so many great sketches over the years that were cut after dress for various reasons and not always because they didn't work just because Sometimes political it's they also don't like the term skit either it's sketch right yeah, yeah, never Never say skit I like it. I like Lauren. I like the
彩排通常在10点到10点半结束。然后直播是在11点半。但我认为这很酷，因为多年来有太多精彩的小品在彩排后因为各种原因被删掉了，并不总是因为它们效果不好，有时是因为政治原因。他们也不喜欢“skit”这个词，应该是“sketch”，对吧？是的，永远不要说“skit”。我喜欢它。我喜欢洛恩（Lorne）。我喜欢……
Yeah, if you if you're feels like a you know, yeah, you're very comfortable in it You're so great at comedy too. Yeah, you're really good at it. Do you have, do you have, you're not a strategic guy, you're so beautifully down to earth with your career, it seems, but do you ask your people to look for comedy versus drama and try to keep a balance there? Or is this kind of like the best grip wins. Yeah, lately now, because I'm trying to change, because I was working consistently,
是的，如果你觉得……你知道，你在其中感到非常自在。你在喜剧方面也很棒。是的，你真的很擅长。你有没有……你不是一个有战略眼光的人，你的职业生涯看起来非常脚踏实地，但你会要求你的团队去寻找喜剧或戏剧角色，并试图保持平衡吗？还是说这更像是“谁最合适谁就赢”？是的，最近是这样，因为我正在尝试改变，因为我一直在持续工作，
basically all through my 30s and now that I have two kids, I've been trying to switch of how I've been working, you know, where I'm, now I'm just like I can't be gone that long and I don't want to be gone that long anymore. So I'm trying to, I'm trying to probably like every game the system and for me the only way is now is trying to work on things from the beginning. If, you know, if I can, but I'm not against it to just whatever, no one's really asked me to do something like that or and I haven't found anything that I really, you know, wanted to do. But if something came along, I would totally do it. But you know, it's sort of like wake up at the middle of the night and stare at the ceiling and go like, I need to do a comedy.
基本上整个30多岁都在工作，现在我有两个孩子了，我一直在尝试改变我的工作方式，你知道，我现在觉得我不能离开那么久，我也不想再离开那么久了。所以我正在尝试，我可能正在尝试像玩游戏一样应对这个系统，对我来说，现在唯一的方法就是尝试从一开始就参与项目。如果，你知道，如果我可以的话，但我并不反对……没人真的要求我做那样的事，或者我还没找到我真正想做的事情。但如果有什么机会出现，我绝对会去做。但你知道，这就像半夜醒来盯着天花板想：“我需要演一部喜剧。”
You know, I'd like to, but I also don't want it to be bad, you know, so I would, you know, the Albert Brooks, to me, is like, you know, the top. Now, there's not a lot of people that are writing like that and you really gotta find them. And yeah, they're tough to find. How old are your kids? Eight months is my youngest in six is one, my other one, so six.
你知道，我想演，但我也不想演得很烂，你知道，所以我会，你知道，阿尔伯特·布鲁克斯（Albert Brooks）对我来说就是顶峰。现在，没有多少人能写出那样的东西，你真的得去寻找他们。是的，他们很难找。你的孩子多大了？我最小的八个月大，另一个六岁，所以是六岁。
My kids are five years apart. All right. Do you, Is that good? It's yeah, I mean, it's it's good because one gets to help you take care of the other or the ones they think they are. But then like, you know, hanging out, you know, at a certain age is like, it's not, you know, when they, what do they know? Seventeen and twelve. It's, you know, like, they're going to be closer when they get older. But they're, they're, they're, there are times when that five year gap is not worse. Although, Jay, maybe I will say one of the nice things I've seen a couple times is your
我的孩子相差五岁。好的。那是好事吗？是的，我的意思是，这很好，因为一个可以帮你照顾另一个，或者他们以为自己能帮上忙。但后来，你知道，在某个年龄段一起玩，并不是……你知道，当他们……他们懂什么？十七岁和十二岁。你知道，他们长大后会更亲近。但他们……他们……有时候那五岁的差距也不是最糟糕的。虽然，杰伊（Jay），也许我会说我见过几次很棒的事情是你的
17 year old dropping your 12 year old at school because they got the same school. That's pretty funny watching. Freddie drop maple was one of the funniest fucking things. That's funny. Yeah, I don't like it. I miss it. How are you liking dad stuff? I love it like it. I miss it. How are you liking dad stuff? I love it.
17岁的孩子送12岁的孩子去上学，因为他们在同一所学校。看着弗雷迪（Freddie）送梅普尔（Maple）去上学真是太搞笑了。那很有趣。是的，我不喜欢它。我想念它。你觉得当爸爸怎么样？我喜欢它。我想念它。你觉得当爸爸怎么样？我喜欢它。
Yeah. Yeah. What you're describing as science fiction to me, the idea that one kid will... Even now, he is very protective over her. And I feel like we gave him, you know, six years of attention and he's totally fine, you know. And if you're like me, you missed, you missed changing diapers, you missed swaddling, you missed like, I was so excited to get to do it again.
是的。是的。你所描述的对我来说就像科幻小说，一个孩子会……即使是现在，他也非常保护她。我觉得我们给了他，你知道，六年的关注，他完全没问题，你知道。如果你像我一样，你错过了换尿布，错过了包裹婴儿，错过了……我太兴奋能再次做这些了。
Oh, I am nice. I know. No. No. This time I'm like, oh, we forgot how much baby's suck. You know, they don't, they don't tell you anything. They get to runny noses and it just destroys the next three days and they have sleep regressions and they're a teething. It's a, I mean, I am more aware this time that I'm like, oh, this is finite.
哦，我很好。我知道。不。不。这一次我心想，哦，我们忘了婴儿有多烦人了。你知道，他们什么都不告诉你。他们流鼻涕，这会毁掉接下来的三天，他们有睡眠倒退，他们在长牙。我的意思是，这一次我更清楚了，我想，哦，这是有限的。
I have to remember this because it's gonna go away quickly. We're the first time I wasn't, I was so anxious for him to get older that I wasn't. And also the first time you're, and also the first time you're not, because you've never done it, you're like, is this normal? Should he be sick this much?
我必须记住这一点，因为它很快就会消失。第一次我不是这样，我太渴望他长大了，所以我没有（珍惜）。而且第一次你……而且第一次你不是，因为你从来没做过，你会想，这正常吗？他应该病得这么厉害吗？
Should he be, should he be not eating, he hasn't eaten for two days. Jesus fucking you end up having those. We have a three and a half year old and we've just kind of just emerging from it again after my older kids are teenagers. And I'm like, fuck man, I just forgot exactly what you're talking about.
他应该……他应该不吃东西吗？他已经两天没吃东西了。天哪，你最终会遇到这些。我们有一个三岁半的孩子，在我的大孩子十几岁之后，我们刚刚又经历了一遍。我心想，该死，我刚好忘了你说的这些。
Just forgot all that shit waking up in the night. All the fucking life. Right, and they're durable. I mean, the first one you don't realize how durable they are in the second one. Yeah, I think it's fun. She's fine. She's okay.
刚好忘了所有那些半夜醒来的破事。所有那些该死的生活。没错，而且他们很耐造。我的意思是，第一个孩子你没意识到他们有多耐造，第二个孩子就知道了。是的，我觉得这很有趣。她很好。她没事。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. So, for soakins. I just want to, well, let's talk about how you diaper your dog. Sean, real quick. No, I just, I just want to get through it. So you guys don't have enough. Again, and then we can go by.
是的，是的，是的。所以，关于索金斯（Sokins）。我只是想，好吧，我们来谈谈你是怎么给你的狗换尿布的，肖恩（Sean），快点。不，我只是，我只是想把它说完。所以你们没有足够的。再说一次，然后我们就可以走了。
Do you want to call Scotty in here? I mean, I did I just I texted him and he said yeah, he said he wrote it's well, he everybody knows it's no secret that me and Scotty are the sky. Sean's husband Scotty is like they the two of them are like the massive Adam might not be up on you. Scotty's you know that's okay I'm saying that's I'm telling Now everybody who listens is listening so Adam when you again, that's like 25 people here we go
你想把斯科蒂（Scotty）叫进来吗？我的意思是，我……我刚给他发了短信，他说好，他说他写了……好吧，大家都知道，我和斯科蒂是……肖恩的丈夫斯科蒂就像……他们俩就像……巨大的亚当（Adam）可能还没跟上。斯科蒂，你知道，没关系，我说的是……我现在告诉大家，听众们都在听，所以亚当，当你再次……那是25个人，我们开始吧。
question please 25 or so I have the obvious stock stock questions which is is it real? Please don't tell me it's not real. Yeah. Please tell me it's all freaking totally real. Totally real. I'm there now. Oh God. I'm there now. No, I want to know like, were you a fan before? What was it like getting, you know, getting like getting that call to be like, you're can ask for this. I think. What was the first one? The first one was like, what are you fan? I grew up, my dad was more of a Star Trek fan than a Star Wars fan, but I did have a couple of Star Wars toys that we got to garage sale, so I was a fan of the movies. And to be asked to do it was, I thought about it a lot because again, I didn't want to
请提问，25个左右，我有显而易见的问题，那就是它是真的吗？请不要告诉我它不是真的。是的。请告诉我这一切完全是真的。完全是真的。我现在就在那里。哦，天哪。我现在就在那里。不，我想知道，你之前是粉丝吗？接到那个电话说“你可以申请这个”是什么感觉？我想。第一个是什么？第一个是……你是粉丝吗？我长大了，我爸爸比起《星球大战》更喜欢《星际迷航》，但我确实有几个在车库拍卖会上买到的《星球大战》玩具，所以我确实是这些电影的粉丝。被邀请去演它，我想了很多，因为同样，我不想
be bad in it. So you got an offer? Yeah, yeah, yeah. I got an offer, but there was no script to read, which I'd never done before. So you had to commit to it. JJ walked me through the whole thing, but there was no script that you could actually see how that how that played out. But also Adam, I'm sure you thought at the time, because I was certainly we had just finished working together. I was very well aware of you, your talent,
在里面表现得很烂。所以你收到了邀请？是的，是的，是的。我收到了邀请，但没有剧本可以读，这是我以前从未做过的。所以你必须承诺去做。J.J.（艾布拉姆斯）带我过了一遍整个过程，但没有剧本让你真正看到它是如何展开的。但亚当，我相信你当时也想过，因为我肯定……我们刚合作完。我非常了解你，你的才华，
your position in the community, what your potential was, as far as jobs and fancy directors and all that stuff. I'm sure at a point, you must have thought, even though you're not a strategic thinker, you know, annoying like that. But so that, well, I don't want to sign up for something where this is going to be louder than anything I'll ever do in my career.
你在圈子里的地位，你的潜力，关于工作和那些大导演等等。我相信在某个时刻，你一定想过，尽管你不是一个战略思想家，你知道，像那样烦人。但是，好吧，我不想签约一个可能会比我职业生涯中做过的任何事情都更响亮的项目。
Am I tying myself to this for multiple films? And did any of that go through your head? I'm sure it must have a little bit. No, actually, no. I never thought that this was going to be the only job I got. I mean, I don't know why I didn't think that it was going to be, I didn't think I'd do anything bigger than that. But I hoped I was optimistic that I would work after it.
我是不是把自己和多部电影绑在一起了？这些念头有没有闪过你的脑海？我相信一定有一点。不，其实没有。我从来没想过这会是我唯一能得到的工作。我的意思是，我不知道为什么我没想过它会是……我没想过我会做比那更大的事情。但我希望，我很乐观，我会在那之后继续工作。
And hopefully not. I wasn't thinking that too far ahead like that of what the end result of it would be because the end result could also be you were in a movie that everybody saw and nobody liked. And they didn't like you in it and they didn't like the movie. And the idea that some, a movie of that scale
希望不会。我没有想得那么远，去想最终结果会是什么，因为最终结果也可能是你演了一部大家都看了但没人喜欢的电影。他们不喜欢你在里面的表现，也不喜欢这部电影。而且那种规模的电影，
that anyone would actually watch it, I guess it was just coming from girls. And this is where I leave you and try to use it. So great. Thanks. And it was very compassionate people about it. Like Sean would be like, what is he doing in this? And he's ruining the franchise.
有人真的会看它，我想这只是来自《都市女孩》（Girls）。还有《这里是我留下的地方》（This Is Where I Leave You），试着去用它。太棒了。谢谢。而且人们对此非常有同情心。就像肖恩会说，他在里面干什么？他在毁掉这个系列。
You don't want that. No, I would never. But it's gotta be cool to go through the process of seeing the drawings of your character than the fittings, the costume fittings, and then touching the props and all that stuff must have been touching the props. Yeah, carefully.
你不想那样。不，我绝不会。但经历看到你角色的图纸，然后是试装，服装试装，然后触摸道具，所有这些事情一定很酷，触摸道具。是的，小心点。
Don't wreck your pants, Sean. Jesus. That is so cool. By the way, you're one of the few people that I turned to Scottie and I said, I have such a massive talent crush on that guy. Yeah. You're so good in everything you do, but especially in love. I agree. And I think you know what is amazing?
别弄坏你的裤子，肖恩。天哪。那太酷了。顺便说一句，你是少数几个我转向斯科蒂说“我对那个家伙有巨大的才华崇拜”的人之一。是的。你在你做的每件事里都很棒，尤其是在《爱》（Girls）里。我同意。而且我认为你知道什么是惊人的吗？
And kind of also this kind of fits in Jason a little bit with what you were saying is like, you, you know, you do like these, you know, a star was one of the most, you know, I don't know if there's a bigger sort of brand in terms of film and, you know, maybe it's sort of the marvel cinema universe and all that kind of shit. But you do that and not only does it not paint you into a corner, it kind of does the opposite. It opens you up to a whole
而且这也有点符合杰森（Jason）你刚才说的，就像，你，你知道，你做这些，你知道，《星球大战》是最大的，你知道，我不知道是否有比这更大的电影品牌，你知道，也许是漫威电影宇宙之类的那些破事。但你做了那个，它不仅没有把你逼进死胡同，反而起到了相反的作用。它向全球所有这些人敞开了大门，然后你继续前进，我在开始时说过，当男孩们试图猜我的嘉宾是谁时，如果你看看你合作过的导演名单，伙计，几乎是无与伦比的。你就是那样。令人惊叹的是，这么多我们这个时代最伟大的导演都邀请你和他们一起踏上这些创作之旅，这一定，感觉非常……而且我想，我也注意到了你谈论事情的方式，
to all these people globally and then you continue going, I said at the start when the boys were trying to guess who my guess was, if you look at the list of directors that you've worked with, it's almost peerless, man. You're in that way. It's just remarkable how many of these incredible, some of the greatest directors of our time have all asked you to come and go on these creative journeys with them, and that's gotta be, feel very, and I guess, I also noticed the way you talk about stuff,
你不是一个战略思想家。看起来你就像，你只是跟着激励你的东西走。我说的对吗？嗯，是的，也不完全是，我在那方面不具战略性。我不会想，哦，这需要赚钱。所以我们……虽然我应该那样想，但我确实明白了，如果你不拍赚钱的电影，他们就会停止让你拍电影。
you're not a strategic thinker. Like it seems like you are like, you just kind of go with what inspires you. Am I right about that a little bit? Well, yes and no, I'm not strategic in that. I'm like, oh, this needs to make money. So we, although I should think that way, where I do get now that you don't do movies that make money, they'll stop asking you to make movies.
这就是我被告知的。但我的想法是，这是电影制作人的媒介，所以我在那方面是有战略的。好吧，那目标不就是和伟大的电影制作人合作吗？而且，你知道，有时我觉得如果我能和它产生共鸣，那么我就可以，但我有我想合作的人，但他们想做的事情，我知道我做不到，或者我觉得我无法达到那个水平。所以我并没有真正回答你的问题。
That's what I've been told. But I, my mind, it's a filmmaker's medium, so I'm strategic in that. Well, isn't the goal then to work with great filmmakers? And, you know, sometimes I feel like if I connect with it, then I can, but I've people that I've wanted to work with where the thing that they wanted to do, I knew I couldn't do or I felt like I wouldn't get there. And so I'm not really answering your question.
但我确实有战略，就像，这是电影制作人的媒介，这是……戏剧或剧作家的媒介。电视似乎是电影制作人的媒介。这是……你知道，戏剧或剧作家的媒介。你知道，电视似乎是编剧的媒介，那是……那些是我一直想合作的人。如果机会出现，我让自己有空去尝试和他们合作。
But I am strategic in that, like, it's a filmmaker's medium, it's a, plays or a playwright's medium. TV seems to be a filmmaker's medium. It's a, you know, plays or a playwright's medium. You know, TV seems to be a writer's medium that's, you know, those are the people that I always wanted to work with. And I made myself available to try to work with them if it came up.
你还在过去两年里扮演了两个非常重要的……意大利男人，一个是设计师。而且都是令人难以置信的创造性思维，如果你想想他们在各自领域所做的事情，对吧？你扮演了毛里齐奥·古驰（Maurizio Gucci）。对。现在你正在扮演恩佐·法拉利（Enzo Ferrari）。我的意思是，那是……
You've also, you've also in the last two years played two very significant portrayed, two very significant. Italian men, one, one a designer. And I'm both both incredible creative minds, if you think about what within their thing, right? You played Mauricio Gucci. Right. And now you're playing currently Enzo Ferrari. I mean, that's...
是的，我想这是一个很好的例子，说明在某种程度上我可能应该更具战略性。就像，我见过很多人，他们会说，我会……我只是碰巧那样做了。我想可能有人会说，也许是因为这会经常出现，你知道，但我会说，好吧，这是雷德利（Ridley Scott）和迈克尔（Michael Mann）。而且，在我看来，一些最好的电影制作人
Yeah, I guess that's a good example of not being strategic in a way that I probably should. Like, I've seen so many people have been like, I'm gonna be like, I'm like, it's just kind of worked out that way. And I think someone probably would have said, like maybe because it's gonna come up a lot, you know, but I'm like, well, it's Ridley and it's Michael. And I, in my mind, some of the best filmmakers
谁在乎连续两个意大利人呢？完全正确。是的，谁在乎呢，而且，就像你说的，两个不可思议的电影制作人和两个伟大的故事。所以谁在乎它是什么呢？你可能会连续拍十个，我想你会的，如果它们是伟大的故事和伟大的导演。是的，好吧，可能不再是意大利人了，
who gives a shit that there's two Italians back to back. Exactly. Yeah, who gives a shit and also, like you said, two incredible filmmakers and two great stories. So who gives a shit what it is? You make 10 in a row probably, I imagine you would, if they were great stories and great directors. Yeah, well probably not Italians anymore though,
但是的，因为我很惊讶它出现的频率这么高，你知道，就像，你，你有什么偏好吗？我说，这只是两个。有两个意大利人，你知道？是的，是的。两个意大利人。因为就像，我心想，哦，对了，媒体……你知道，这些事情不是一个地方，或者我的意思是，这是，
but yeah, because I'm surprised how much it comes up, you know, it's like, you know, are you have a thing? I'm like, it's two. There's two Italians, you know? Yeah, yeah. Two Italians. Because it's like, I'm like, oh, right, pre, pre, you know, that these things are not a place, or I mean, this is,
但媒体不是一个你可以进行细致入微对话的地方。没错。这似乎是一个很难的想法，比如，意大利是怎么回事？好吧，我的意思是，这与意大利关系不大，虽然我喜欢它，但这更多是关于雷德利·斯科特和迈克尔·曼以及项目本身。意大利不是我脑子里的第一件事。没错，罗伯特，你不是在给你的经纪人打电话说，
but press isn't a place that you have a nuanced conversation. Right. And that seems like a hard idea of like, well, what is it with Italy? Well, I mean, it's less to do with Italy, although I like it, but it's more about Ridley Scott and Michael Mann who end the projects themselves. And Italy is not the first thing on my mind. Right, Robert, you're not calling your age as going like,
嘿，给我另一个伟大的意大利角色来演。是的，没错，没错。来吧，我听说，这不像你不是在给你的经纪人打电话说嘿给我另一个伟大的意大利角色来演。是的，没错，没错，这里还没做完。那个市场，你之前对赛车感兴趣吗？不，可能没有。我对车感兴趣，我没有……车，自行车。是的，你知道，我不是……你知道，我主要从《迈阿密风云》（Miami Vice）里知道法拉利。你知道，是的，而且……而且它是不可企及的，它只是不是我成长经历的一部分，你知道。没错。好吧，再说一次，迈克尔·曼就在那里。
hey, give me another great Italian role, they'll play. Yeah, right, right. Come parry, I hear, it's not like you're not calling your ages going like hey give me another great Italian role to play Yeah, right right here is not done That market what about what about we you into car racing at all beforehand? No, it's probably didn't I was into cars I didn't the car bike. Yeah, you know, I wasn't you know, I knew of Ferrari's mostly from Miami vice You know, yeah and take it And take it with unattainable, it just wasn't part of my upbringing, you know. Right. Well, again, Michael Mann right there.
你像是一个体育迷吗？你参加很多运动，拳击，之类的。就像，我知道我喜欢看，我有点停留在90年代末的迈克尔·乔丹时代。没错。所以我只是最近，因为我试图少工作，
Are you like, it's like a sports guy, you play a lot of sports, boxing, and like that. Like, I know I like watching, I'm kind of stuck in time a little bit with late 90s Michael Jordan. Right. So I'm just now only recently, because I'm trying to work less,
我又开始去看篮球了。但篮球是我的运动。这让你成为尼克斯队的粉丝还是篮网队的粉丝？是的，这让我成为尼克斯队的粉丝，因为我在布鲁克林。尼克斯？是的。没错。
I've gotten back into going to basketball. But basketball is my sport. Does that make you a next fan or a pastors fan? Yeah, it makes me a next fan, because I'm in Brooklyn. A next? Yeah. Right.
是的，所以篮球是你的爱好，但你不是那种看橄榄球比赛的人，或者类似的东西。不，不，不，不，我希望我是。我的意思是，有时我看橄榄球，但不是真的。我的意思是，我看泰森（Tyson）的集锦，但我不会跟上最新的……我错过了泰森·富里（Tyson Fury）的比赛，我不是一个完全的泰森迷。记得迈克·泰森吗？看着他对别人做的事情真是太可怕了。
Yeah. And so, so basketball is your thing, but you're not like a watch football day kind of guy, or anything like that. No, no, no, no, I wish I did. I mean, sometimes I watch football a day, but not really. I mean, I watch Tyson highlights, but like my Tyson highlights, but I won't keep up today with the, like I missed the Tyson Fury fight and I'm not a full-max Tyson. Remember Mike Tyson was just like, it was just horrific watching what he would do to people.
我无法停止观看。自从他之后我们就没有那样的拳击手了，对吧？没有。没有，我的意思是，叫什么名字，那个家伙，那个英国人，他是，什么，你刚才说了他？泰森·富里。泰森·富里，是的。他一直相当有统治力，但不是以同样的方式。
And I could not stop watching. We haven't had a boxer like that since him, have we? No. No, I mean, what's his name, the guy, the English guy, who's, what, you just said him? Tyson Fury. Tyson Fury, yeah. He's been fairly dominant, but not in that same way.
他上一场比赛，他不是被击倒了两次，第三次吗？那是UFC，对吧？那是UFC。我不能，你知道，我相信我们会有一些粉丝会说，你知道，成熟点，但我发现UFC太黑暗了。哦，太棒了。那种能量对我来说太黑暗了。
There's last fight, didn't he get knocked down twice to a third time? That's all UFC, right? It's all UFC. I can't, you know, I'm sure we'll have some fans who are like, you know, grow up, but I find UFC to be so dark. Oh, great. The energy is so dark for me.
我不知道。它有某种东西。它看起来很真实。我曾经在睡觉前看它。有一次在半夜，在梦里，我以为我在打架，我对着一个男人挥了一肘。我差点打中她的鼻子。哦，我只是对着她睡觉的枕头笑了，
I don't know. There's something about it. It seems real. I used to watch it right before I got to bed. One time in the middle of the night in my dream, I thought I was in a fight and I threw an elbow at a man-dop. And I just missed her freaking nose. Oh, I just laughed at pillow that she was sleeping on
因为我在梦里打架。你看UFC吗？就在我睡觉前，那是最愚蠢的事情。就像，我是不是也该吃一大块牛排？我本该杀了某人的。我不知道。总之，我们离题了。我们马上回来。
because I was in a fight in my dream. Did you watch the UFC? Right before I went to bed, it was like a stupidest thing. It's like, am I supposed to have a big stake too? I should have done it killing somebody. I don't know. Anyway, we digress. We'll be right back.
本集部分由Helix赞助。嘿，伙计们，让我告诉你们一个睡眠领域的游戏规则改变者：Helix床垫。现在，我已经用了我的Helix床垫快四年了，这简直是一场睡眠革命。睡眠就是一切，对吧？它给你能量，给你专注力。它决定了你一天的情绪，
This episode is brought to you in part by Helix. Hey guys, let me tell you about a game changer in the sleep department Helix mattresses. Now, I've had my Helix mattress for almost four years and it's been a total sleep revolution. Sleep is everything, right? It gives you energy, it gives you focus. It sets your mood for the day,
而Helix一直是我这段时间的帮手。这是我Dusk Lux床垫的新一天黎明。呃，那太糟糕了。我还在我的Helix床垫上醒来。Helix不仅仅提供一种适合所有人的尺寸。拥有20种独特的床垫，包括屡获殊荣的Luxe系列和专为大个子设计的Helix Elite，
and Helix has been a help for me this whole time. It's a dawn for a new day with my dusk lux. Ugh, that was bad. I'm still waking up on my Helix mattress. Helix doesn't just offer one size fits all. With 20 unique mattresses, including the award-winning Luxe Collection and the Helix Elite designed for big
他们有适合每个人的产品。那么，你如何找到你的完美匹配？很简单。参加Helix睡眠测试，不到两分钟，你就会知道什么床垫适合你的身体和睡眠偏好。你猜怎么着？它免费运送到你家门口！我参加了测试，并匹配到了我梦想中的床垫。非常感谢Helix。Helix为我们的听众提供所有床垫订单25%的折扣和两个免费枕头，有效期至1月7日。
and tall sleepers, they've got something for everyone. Now, how do you find your perfect match? Easy. Take the Helix sleep quiz, and under two minutes, you'll know what mattress suits your body and sleep preferences. And guess what? It ships to your door, free of charge! I take the quiz and got matched with my dream mattress. Thank you so much, Helix. Helix is offering 25% up all mattress orders and two free pillows for our listeners through January 7th.
前往helixsleep.com/smartless并使用代码helixpartner25。这是他们迄今为止最好的优惠，而且不会持续太久。Helixsleep.com/smartless代码helixpartner25，有了Helix，更好的睡眠现在就开始了。嘿，Smartless听众。这条信息来自我们很酷的赞助商，那不勒斯、马可岛和大沼泽地，
Go to helixsleep.com slash smartless and use code helixpartner25. This is their best offer yet and it won't last long. Helixsleep.com slash smartless code helixpartner25 with helix better sleep starts now. Hey there, Smartless listener. This message comes from our cool sponsor, Naples, Marco Island and the Everglades,
佛罗里达的天堂海岸。想象一下在30英里原始的海湾海岸线上放松，从僻静的基韦恩岛到时髦的海滨度假村。他们有适合每个人的地方。冒险迷们准备好在无尽的红树林、河口和海岸线上进行狂野之旅吧。划船、钓鱼、潜水和大量的打高尔夫球，
Florida's Paradise Coast. Imagine chilling on 30 miles of pristine Gulf Shoreline from the secluded Keyway in Island to Swanky Beachfront Resorts. They've got a spot for everyone. Adventure junkies get ready for a wild ride through endless mangroves, estuaries, and shorelines. Boating, fishing, diving, and tons of golf,
他们应有尽有，感觉很时髦。在那不勒斯的高档精品店、艺术画廊和世界级水疗中心犒劳自己。我的意思是，来吧，还有什么比在柏树间伴随着海湾微风的舒缓声音中休息更放松的呢？穿着轮椅多年。美食家们，这是给你们的。沉浸在新鲜的海湾海鲜和海湾微风的声音中，混合各种风味。开始策划你的下一次冒险。再说一次，那是ParadiseCoast.com/smartless。祝旅行愉快。
they got it all, feeling fancy. Treat yourself to upscale boutique's art galleries and world-class spas in Naples. I mean, come on, what's more relaxing than lounging amid cipristries to the soothing sounds of golf breezes? Wearing a wheelchair in all the years. Foodies, this one's for you. Dive into a mix of flavors with fresh from the golf seafood sounds of gulf breezes. to start plotting your next adventure. One more time, that's ParadiseCoast.com slash smartless. Happy travels.
现在回到节目。亚当，你打算……还有更多关于《星球大战》的事情吗？比如，我不知道。哦，天哪，看，他又回来了。是的，那是回来了。他们在做一些事情，是的，但不是和我一起。我没在做。
And now back to the show. Adam, are you gonna, is there any more talk about more Star Wars stuff? Like, I don't know. Oh, boy, look, he's back. Yeah, that is back. They're doing stuff, yeah, but not with me. I'm not doing it.
所以你因为角色的事情结束了。是的。是的。好吧。然后，但是不是和我一起。我没在做。所以你因为角色的事情结束了。是的。好吧。然后，但是等等，你做了吗？但是你会吗？但是如果你做了，你觉得什么角色？我的名字是……
So you're done because of the characters stuff. Yeah. Yeah. All right. And so, and then, but not with me. I'm not doing it. So you're done because of the character stuff. Yeah. All right. And then, but wait, did you? But would you? But if you did, what character do you think? My name is...
我的名字是……我明天来找你，如果J.J.对此真的很友善的话。不，我想知道，你能给我讲一个拍摄过程中很棒、出错或令人惊讶的好故事吗？或者，哦，你知道吗，你知道吗，我喜欢这个。这是我喜欢的。当它在《原力觉醒》的结尾时，
My name is... I came to you tomorrow and... If JJ was really nice about it. No, I want to know, can you just give me one good story from filming something that was great or went wrong or something that was surprising? Or, oh, you know what, you know what, I loved. This is what I loved. When it was at the end of Forza Wacens
你正在和蕾伊（Rey）进行最后的战斗。就像他被困在动漫展的电梯里一样。而你该死的，这是你该死的噩梦。我只是想说我在做什么。我再也不会遇到那个家伙了。所以，我希望我能。但当你受伤时，当她抓住你时，你在绕圈走，
and you're doing the final battle with Ray. It's like he's stuck in an elevator at Comic Con. And you're fucking, it's your fucking nightmare first. I just want to say what I'm doing. I'm never gonna run into the guy, ever again. So, I hope I do. But when you're wounded, when she got you, and you're walking around in a circle,
你开始拍打你的臀部侧面，像这样，试图让疼痛消失或什么的，因为它在流血。是的，是的，是的。谁的主意？那真是个很酷、很具体的演员动作。我从来没见过。太酷了。谢谢。
and you start banging the side of your hip, like this, trying to get like the pain away or something, because it's bleeding. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Who's ideal? Is that such a cool, specific actor? I've never seen that. So cool. Thanks.
我实际上可以合法地说那是我的。那个想法，我们……它是如何向我推销的，同样，这些都没有写下来，但最开始的是，他的旅程应该是阿纳金（Anakin）的对立面，他开始时几乎是最……与一个从一开始就最黑暗，然后到系列结束时变得最脆弱的人相反，他开始时几乎是最……与一个从一开始就最黑暗，然后到系列结束时变得最脆弱的人相反，他开始时最脆弱，并一点一点地变得更致力于黑暗面。我觉得最终他们，我想，摆脱了那个想法，但在我扮演它时，这就是我努力的方向。所以所有这些东西，任何时候，即使是抽象地，到电影结束时，任何开始进入他世界的东西，都是他的想法，他很脆弱，他必须摆脱它。所以，我想只是以抽象的方式。好吧，那么当你受伤流血时，你心想，我必须摆脱这个。就像，是的，是的，是的。这不是很有意识。我没有有意识地去想它。我想那就像这种痛苦。他试图扑灭任何东西。他变得越来越多。所以当我们杀掉汉（Han）之后，你知道，希望你在他的脸上看到他转变了，你知道，他做出了一个选择，他要致力于黑暗面。是的，是的。他喜欢那种节奏吗，你知道，所有的特效和特技之类的？我想因为他们奢侈的日程安排，你不需要每天拍很多页。
I will actually legit me say that was mine. That the idea that we, how it was pitched to me was, again, none of these were written, but that very beginning was that his journey was supposed to be the opposite ofators in that he starts almost the most, as opposed to someone who's the most dark from the beginning and then by the end of the series becomes the most vulnerable that he starts almost the most, as opposed to someone who's the most dark from the beginning, and then by the end of the series becomes the most vulnerable, that he starts the most vulnerable and becomes little by little more committed to the dark side. I feel like eventually they, they, I think, got rid of that idea, but in my mind as I was playing it, that's what I was working towards. So all of this stuff is anytime that even abstractly that by the end of the movie it starts anything that starts to come
你，我只记得和你一起工作，你喜欢保持良好的势头。你，你保持在状态中，你准备好了。你是如何能够随着缓慢的节奏加速和减速的？这是一个巨大的调整。即使在《这里是我留下的地方》中，我也没完全弄清楚在哪里可以完全经济地表演。所以中间的休息，我从来没弄清楚电影片场的语言。所以我还在摸索。
into his world, there are minds in that he's vulnerable, he has to get rid of it. So, I think just in the abstract way it was. Okay, so then when you got wounded and you were bleeding, you're like, I got to get rid of this. Like, yeah, yeah, yeah. It wasn't very conscious. I wasn't consciously thinking of it. I think that that's just like this pain. He's trying to snuff out anything. He's getting more and more. So by the time we're after he kills Han, you know, hopefully that you see in his face that he shifts into, you know, he's made a choice that he's going to commit to the dark side. Yeah, yeah. How does he like the pace of that, you know, it's all all the effects and stunts and things like that? I would imagine because of their luxury of schedule too, that you didn't have to shoot a lot of pages every day.
所以我浪费了很多精力试图保持某种引擎运转。那是，我拍《星球大战》对我来说比我……我让它比应该的更累人。因为我之前没有太多那么大片场的势头。我工作过的所有东西都很小，而且移动得很快。
You, I just remember working with you that you'd like to keep a nice momentum going. You, you stay in it and you're ready. How are you able to throttle up and throttle back with the slow pace? There's a massive adjustment. Even when this is where I leave you, I hadn't quite figured out where to be economical at all. So the breaks in between, I'd never figured out the language of a film set. So I was still figuring it out.
所以你学到了什么？我喜欢那个想法。是的，我记得有人说，我从来不对某人说，刚休息完然后拍几个镜头，我就心想，该死，拍电影，太无聊了。因为这只是需要该死的时间太长了，
So I was wasting just like a lot of energy trying to keep something like kind of an engine going. That was, I made Star Wars was way more exhausting for me than I, I made it more exhausting than it should have been. Because I had quite a bit of the momentum of a set that was that big before. All the things that worked on were really small and they moved pretty fast.
而且你中间有所有这些大块的时间。而且，你怎么保持状态，尤其是在拍喜剧的时候？你心想，拍一部好的喜剧电影太难了，因为只是……拍一部好的喜剧电影太难了，因为只是没有势头。势头。你需要那个来保持它，对吧？所以你主动做了什么来训练自己
So what did you learn? I love that idea. Yeah, I remember somebody saying, I never say to somebody like, coming off rest of them and then doing a couple of moves and I was like, fuck, make it a movie, so boring. And because it was just take so fucking long
在电影中表演，有什么不同吗？你有什么像技巧之类的东西吗？是的，好吧，通常导演会设定片场的节奏。我不喜欢成为那个试图控制片场节奏或韵律的人。我有点让那个人……你知道，他们有点……所以我必须调整，就像斯派克·李（Spike Lee）和索德伯格（Soderbergh）拍得非常快。
and you have all this big time in between. And like, how do you stay in, especially making a comedy? You're like, it's so hard to make a good comedy movie because there's just, it's so hard to make a good comedy movie because there's just no momentum. Momentum. And you need that to keep it up, right? And so what did you do actively to kind of train yourself
对我来说，那不舒服，但那是他们的电影。所以我调整以适应他们正在做的事情。所以像那样的事情，我不会回到拖车里，我大部分时间都待在片场，然后如果我需要逃避，你知道，谈话，你知道，侧面谈话，那么我会，只是为了保持专注，如果你知道，关于《星球大战》的问题之类的。是的，一些该死的书呆子。是的，你正试图进入恩佐·法拉利的状态，你还有最后一件事。
to perform in films that was different? Did you have something like a technique? Yeah, well, usually the director sets the pace of the set. I don't like to be the person that tries to control the pace or rhythm of the set. I kind of let the person that's to, you know, they kind of, and so I have to adjust, like Spike Lee and Soderberg shoot really fast.
当他们在沃特-汉（Volt-Hand）星球上时，加勒比海的太阳烧掉了他们的头盔是真的吗？肖恩，在所有《星球大战》宇宙的所有角色中，你觉得你最想扮演什么角色？我？是的，C-3PO。卢克·天行者（Luke Skywalker），当然。是的。哈。卢克·天行者。是的，当然。好吧，用低八度，也许。那是什么？那是什么？保罗（Paul）？是的。我们想去，关于塔希站（Tashi station）的事情。我们想回到塔希站或者什么的。马克·哈米尔（Mark Hamill）说，这真的很爱抱怨。
And for me, that's not comfortable, but it's their movie and their film. So I adjust to what it is that they're doing. So things like that, I won't go back to the trailer, I'll stay on set mostly, and then if I need to escape, you know, a conversation, you know, a side conversation, then I will just to try to stay focused if you know, for questions about Star Wars or something. Yeah, some fucking boober nerds. Yeah, you're trying to get into being in zofrari and you got one more thing.
那是一句如此有趣的台词。现在每个人都拿它开玩笑，但它太……它太棒了。哦，对了。是的。你知道我在说什么，我想回到镇上去拿一些动力转换器在塔希站。我记得。那是第一个，对吧？
When they were on planet, Volt-Hand, was it true that the Caribbean sun burned their helmets off? Sean of all the characters at all the Star Wars universe, what character do you think you would have liked to have played the most? Me? Yeah, you three PO. Luke Skywalker, of course. Yeah. Huh. Luke Skywalker. Yeah, of course. Well, with a lower octave, maybe. What's that? What's that? Paul? Yeah. We want to go, something about the Tashi station. We wanted to go back to the Tashi station or something. Mark Hamill says, it's really whining.
那是第一个。最后，我们结束《星球大战》的话题了。但你很高兴不必长篇大论地谈论它吗？我知道我们在这里谈了一点，但你是不是，你尽量避免，你知道，你尽量专注于向前看？不，我不，老实说，没有多少人跟我谈论它。当他们谈论时，他们大多问我，
It's such a funny line. Everybody makes fun of it now, but it's so, it was so great. Oh, right. Yeah. You know, I'm talking about, I wanted to go back in the town to pick up some power converters in the Tashi station. I remember. That's the first one, right?
即使是你问的时候也和大多数人问我不一样。所以，关于它唯一的事情是，当他们谈论时，他们大多问我。即使是你问的时候也和大多数人问我不一样。关于它唯一的事情是，我经常会长篇大论地谈论你试图支持的某部电影。然后你说了一句关于《星球大战》的话。那这就成了那件事，迈克尔。没错。是的，那首先是重点。
That's the first one. And last, we're done with the Star Wars. But are you so happy to not have to talk about it at length? I know we did a little bit here, but are you like, you try to avoid, like, you know, do you try to focus on moving forward? No, I don't, honestly, not a lot of people talk to me about it. When they do, they mostly ask me,
是的，是的，是的，是的。你怀念在布鲁克林拍系列剧吗？我怀念。我怀念，我怀念。对吧？你真的觉得你会喜欢那个吗？是的，好吧，因为我会……是的，是的，是的，是的。你怀念在布鲁克林拍系列剧吗？我怀念，我怀念，我怀念，我怀念。对吧？你真的吗？我喜欢那个。是的，好吧，因为我会离家很近，而且……
even when you're asking is different than when most people ask me. So, and the only thing about it when they do, they mostly ask me. Even what you're asking is different than what most people ask me. And the only thing about it is I would talk at length often about some movie that you're trying to support. And then you say one thing about Star Wars. And that becomes the thing there, Michael. Right. Yeah, that first was the point of it.
是的，我没意识到那有多奢侈。等等，你已经说过这个了，你最初来自哪里？印第安纳州。印第安纳州。哦，看看谁刚加入播客。你说了。我们谈过几次了。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Do you miss shooting a series in Brooklyn? I do. I do, I do. Right? Do you really think you'd love that? Yeah, well, because I'd be Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Do you miss shooting a series in Brooklyn? I do, I do, I do, I do. Right? Do you really? I love that. Yeah, well, because I'd be close to home and like,
他当时处于断片状态，试图构思一个《星球大战》的问题。你知道大多数人，当他们在对话中交谈时，他们不会花所有时间去想当别人说话时我要说什么。只是听。我不知道对话是怎么发生的。所以你对此有什么感觉？我觉得当人们……你曾经想过搬到印第安纳州吗？是的。你永远不会住在洛杉矶。那只是不是你的速度。不，他做过。不，是的，不，我知道。那不是我的，我喜欢四季。是的，是的，是的。我明白了，我明白了。
yeah, I didn't realize how luxurious that was. Wait, you said this already, where are you from originally? Indiana. Indiana. Oh, look who just joined the podcast. You said it. We talked about it a few times.
是的，我的。天哪，最近关于洛杉矶和纽约，我们谈得太多了，对吧？JB，我们那天晚上在谈论。是的。我在纽约住了20多年。当我离开时，当我的孩子，当我的大孩子还小的时候，我搬到了洛杉矶，我心想，我不知道我是否还想搬回纽约。
He was in a blackout trying to form a Star Wars question. You know most people, when they talk in the conversation, they don't spend all their time thinking about what I'm going to say when other people are talking. Just listen. I don't know how the conversation happens. So what's your feeling about? I think it's fascinating when people... Would you ever move to Indiana? Yeah. You would never live in Los Angeles. It's not just not your speed. No, he did. No, yeah, no, I know. It's not my, I enjoy the four seasons. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I get it, I get it.
而现在这些天，越来越多，我心想，我渴望住在纽约。16。我的意思是，我很乐意。为什么你这么说？我只是很乐意，因为季节，因为，那里有这么多不同的行业以那里为中心。
Yeah, mine. God, that's been coming up so much lately with us about LA and New York, right? JB, we were talking about the other night. Yeah. And I lived in New York for over 20 years. And when I left, when my kids, when my older kids were little, I moved to LA and I was like, I don't know if I ever wanna move to New York.
所以你交谈的人对很多你一无所知的事情都有话可说。是的，它不是一个公司城镇，像洛杉矶。那真是一个公司城镇。没错，没错，没错。它确实很无聊。在那方面，我们总是说，如果你的所有参考资料都只是关于这个，
And now these days, more and more, I'm like, I've been dying to live back in New York. 16. I mean, I would love. Why'd you say? I would just love to, because of the seasons, because of the, there's so many different industries that are centered there.
那么你知道，你在做什么。是的，这就是我来这里时的感觉，但我没有……参考资料都只是关于这个，那么你知道。你在做什么？是的，这就是我来这里时的感觉，但我没想过我是，也许我只是，因为每次我来，都是为了与那个相关的事情。我心想，好吧，我其实从来没在这里待过，所以我不能真的那么说，但感觉是那样的。感觉就像，对于纽约，
So the people you talk to have something to say about so many things you know nothing about. Yeah, it's not a company town, like L.A. It's such a company town. Right, right, right. It is boring though. In that way, we always say that, like if all your references are just about this,
还有很多其他的事情在发生，与那个无关。这很刺激，你知道吗？确实。每个人都在工作，做着你一无所知的事情。这很刺激。你知道吗？确实。每个人都在工作，做着你一无所知的事情。这非常有趣。如果可以的话，离开城市也很好，
then you know, what you're working on. Yeah, that's what I feel when I come here, but I didn references are just about this, then you know. What's your workin' on? Yeah, that's what I feel when I come here, but I didn't think I was like, maybe I'm just, because every time I come, it's for something that is related to that too. I'm like, well, I've actually never spent time here, so I can't really say that, but it feels that way. It feels like, with New York,
如果你不能，因为你可能只是坐在公寓里，感受到外面那个地方的能量，觉得你需要做点什么，这也可能让人精疲力竭。但我知道我爱纽约。不，他们总是。是的，希望如此。是的。
there's just so much other shit goin' on that is nothing to do with that. It's stimulating, you know? It is. Everybody's workin' doin' somethin' that you don't know anything it. It's stimulating. You know? It is. Everybody's working doing something that you don't know anything about. It's very interesting. Which, if you can, it's also nice to get out of the city
是的，我刚才就是那样戴上你的眼镜的。是的，我有一个问题要问你们三个，你们三个。是的，我也会。希望如此。是的。是的，抱歉。戴上你的眼镜。是的，我有一个问题要问你们三个。你们三个都有孩子。当你第一次带你的孩子去学校时，那一定就像，我想处理……我必须见每个人。你好吗？
if you can't, because you can just be sitting in your apartment and feel the energy of the place outside and feel like you need to be doing something, which is also like can be exhausting. But I know I love New York. No, they all always. Yeah, hopefully. Yeah.
然后他们要求问你愚蠢的问题。就像，我问你亚当，愚蠢的问题，或者什么的，你会发现自己被老师或其他家长困住，或者什么的。你是怎么处理所有这些的？因为你是一个知名人士。是的，你在公众视野中。我，当我儿子出生时，当他在，在他上学之前，
Yeah, that's how I just put your glasses. Yeah, I have a question for all three of you with you all three of them. Yeah, I would too. Hopefully. Yeah. Yeah, sorry. Put your glasses on. Yeah, I have a question for all three of you. You all three up kids. When you take your kid to a school for the first time, it's gotta be like, I want to deal with the... I have to meet everybody. How are you?
我真的没有带他出去太多，因为我不想让人们打扰他。然后有一次我在意大利带他出去，立刻，你知道，我们就像，哦，这是大流行。就像显然没有人跟着我们，砰，他们抓住了我们，人们拍了我孩子的照片。但后来它有点像我应该带他出去的程度，我错过了所有这些破事。
And then they are asking to ask you dumb questions. Like, I'm asking you Adam, dumb questions, or whatever, you're gonna find yourself trapped by teachers or other parents or whatever. How do you deal with all that? Because you're a known person. Yeah, you're in the public eye. I, when my son was born, when he was in, before he was in school,
然后他们会问你一些愚蠢的问题。就像我问你亚当，一些愚蠢的问题，或者其他什么，你会发现自己被老师或其他家长之类的困住了。你是怎么处理这些的？因为你是个名人。是的，你处于公众视野中。我，当我儿子出生时，当他在，在他上学之前，
I didn't really go outside with him much because I didn't want people to bother him. And then the one time I went out with him in Italy, immediately, you know, we were like, oh, it's the pandemic. Like clearly no one's following us and boom, they got us and people took pictures of my kid. But then it was kind of like to point where I should go outside with I'm missing out on all this shit.
我其实不太带他出门，因为我不想让别人打扰他。然后有一次我在意大利带他出去，立刻，你知道，我们当时想，哦，那是疫情期间。显然没人跟着我们，结果砰的一声，他们抓住了我们，人们拍了我孩子的照片。但后来我觉得我应该带他出去，我错过了所有这些事情。
So do you get hassled? Do you get hounded a lot by paparazzi and stuff like that? Not paparazzi necessarily, but people. And it's all good. It's fine, but after, when you're with your kid and you're trying to do something, then now he's at the age where he's starting to track like put it together.
所以你会受到骚扰吗？你会被狗仔队之类的东西缠住吗？不一定是狗仔队，但确实会有人。这都还好。没关系，但后来，当你和孩子在一起，想做点什么的时候，他现在到了开始察觉并把事情联系起来的年纪了。
Yeah, yeah. So what does it look like for you? I mean, I do want to ask you a little bit about, um, about Ferrari. Cause you, you know, I'm sorry, but we're with, I can't wait to see it. I know. Working with Michael, man, obviously, what was that process like for you? Cause I mean, it was pretty on-composing, I imagine. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It was prosthetics that we didn't realize we're going to be as involved. We had no money. Well, I mean, we had money, but we had not a lot of money for how Michael wanted to do it and not a lot of time.
是啊，是啊。那对你来说是什么样的呢？我是说，我确实想问你一点关于，嗯，关于《法拉利》的事。因为你，你知道，抱歉，但我们和，我迫不及待想看了。我知道。和迈克尔合作，伙计，显然，那个过程对你来说是怎样的？因为我是说，我想那一定很令人敬畏。是啊。是啊。是啊。是啊。那是我们没意识到会那么复杂的假体化妆。我们没钱。好吧，我是说，我们有钱，但对于迈克尔想要的效果来说，钱不够，时间也不够。
So it was very, you know, 17-hour days, sometimes a couple of times, 20-hour days. And in Modena, you know, where everything was happening, where everything happened for Enzo. It's like the barber shop he went to, the same, the grandson of the guy who actually was his barber, the actual factory, the place where the crash was, everything is very meticulous and authentic and incredibly thoroughly researched and, you know, going to the factory and seeing the engines, shipping in the actual, some of the actual cars that won the Mielemea, some of these $70 million for Aris that he would just bring there just to get the sound, and hook up nine mics to them and but at the same time, he's very researched, but is after something pretty abstract. He's famously well researched and very
所以，你知道，那是很辛苦的，17小时的工作日，有时甚至几次达到20小时。在摩德纳，你知道，那是所有事情发生的地方，恩佐经历一切的地方。就像他去过的理发店，那个理发师的孙子，真正的工厂，发生车祸的地方，一切都非常细致、真实，而且研究得极其彻底。你知道，去工厂看引擎，运来一些真正赢得过米勒大赛的赛车，其中一些价值7000万美元的法拉利，他只是为了录音就把它们带到那里，接上九个麦克风。但与此同时，他虽然做了很多研究，但追求的是一些相当抽象的东西。他以研究深入而闻名，而且非常
meticulous about clothes and sound and all of the details. But then is very good about making shit up in the moment. Well, you mentioned, maybe, vice. I was a huge, maybe vice fan of the show. Oh, God, you have the show. Yeah, because I was a young teen when that show was like that. Dude, when DJ Don Johnson knows this, I've told him he knows this. When he shaved his head that like third season or whatever went to a buzz cut, I did it. That's how I do it I was. I thought it was so fucking cool. I'd never seen anything like it. And part of it was, A. Don is great.
对服装、声音和所有细节都一丝不苟。但他在现场即兴发挥的能力也很强。嗯，你提到了，也许是《迈阿密风云》。我曾是《迈阿密风云》的超级粉丝。哦，天哪，你看了那个剧。是啊，因为那部剧火的时候我还是个少年。伙计，当唐·约翰逊知道这一点时，我告诉过他，他知道。当他在第三季左右把头发剃成寸头时，我也照做了。我就是那样，我觉得那简直酷毙了。我从未见过那样的东西。部分原因是，A. 唐很棒。
It was so cool. But the way that Michael Mann understood the making of the film, the balance of, you know, really, you know, cool setups, really cool shots. He, you know, really making the most of it, setting the tone that he was able to set. And with the music, he was the first guy who made like really cool mod, like it was almost like a lot of those shows were almost like music videos in the middle that had these incredible montages. And yeah, it was just breathtaking to watch him, you know, do all that shit.
那太酷了。但迈克尔·曼理解电影制作的方式，那种平衡，你知道，真的很酷的布景，真的很酷的镜头。他，你知道，真的充分利用了这些，设定了他所能设定的基调。还有音乐，他是第一个把那种真的很酷的摩登风格，就像那些剧集中间几乎像是音乐录影带，有这些令人难以置信的蒙太奇。是的，看着他做所有这些事情简直令人叹为观止。
There's that really famous one where they have in the air tonight with Phil Collins that whole sequence. The camera set up on the side of the car, you're watching the wheel and then it's going down the thing and then it's the reflection off the hood and then he goes to that phone booth that's miraculously at the end of a pier all by itself.
有一个非常著名的片段，他们用了菲尔·柯林斯的《In the Air Tonight》，整个序列。摄像机架在车侧面，你看着轮子，然后它沿着东西走，然后是引擎盖上的倒影，然后他走到那个奇迹般地独自立在码头尽头的电话亭。
That calls as X-Wife. Clause as X-Wife, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah, all by itself. That's right. Causes ex-wife. Causes ex-wife, yes. Yeah, yeah, yeah, great shit. And you watch that. I mean, that was like 1984, man. And like just elevated shit. Yeah, he's very into rewatching his movies now. He's obsessed with internal life.
那是打给前妻的。打给前妻，是的。是啊，是啊，是啊，独自一人。没错。打给前妻。打给前妻，是的。是啊，是啊，是啊，太棒了。你看着那个。我是说，那是1984年的事了，伙计。简直是高水准的东西。是的，他现在非常热衷于重看自己的电影。他痴迷于内心生活。
He really believes in it that's cinematic and interesting enough. Then when I watch, like last in Mohicans or he Or the last in Mohicans in particular. They don't have a lot of screen time to really fall in love But because they're you can tell they're so you know Field you know internally you totally buy it and he's really into that all of his notes are about internal stuff He's really rare in that way Not a lot of directors really talk about internal issues.
他真的相信那是电影化的，而且足够有趣。然后当我观看，比如《最后的莫希干人》，或者他，或者特别是《最后的莫希干人》。他们没有太多的银幕时间来真正坠入爱河，但因为你可以看出他们，你知道，内心深处，你完全相信，他真的很热衷于此。他所有的笔记都是关于内心层面的东西。他在这一点上真的很罕见。没有多少导演真的谈论内心问题。
No, shit. And then he trusts that the audience can kind of read your mind a little bit. If you're really cooking inside, you don't need to say it. They'll lean forward and try to read you. And is that, and is that about staging in the way that he shoots it, that, that to him in order to kind of reveal, to get into that interliving? Yeah, yeah. He's all about yeah. All of his choices are about, there's this thing where he's obsessed with ties.
可不是嘛。然后他相信观众能读懂你的心思。如果你内心真的在酝酿，你不需要说出来。他们会前倾并试图读懂你。那是，那是关于他拍摄时的舞台调度吗，对他来说，为了揭示，为了进入那种内心生活？是啊，是啊。他全神贯注于此。他所有的选择都是关于，他有一种对领带的执念。
There's a lot of famous stories about him. Like, you know, someone will say an offhanded comment and I'm like, oh, that's a nice tie. He's like, what'd you say? And they're like, oh, he's just saying that he had a nice tie. He's like, okay, we gotta go find another tie. And I'll spend two hours finding the right tie.
关于他有很多著名的故事。比如，你知道，有人会随口说一句，我就说，哦，那条领带真不错。他会说，你说什么？他们会说，哦，只是说他领带好看。他会说，好吧，我们得去换一条领带。然后我会花两个小时找合适的领带。
And then you ask him, he's like, well, if you're looking at the tie then you're not looking at the actress face. And I want you to be like engrossed in what's going on in the, he's like the blacks in the scene are right. They need to be 50% like darker, because then you can really get into the pupils, you know? It's all about like internal life.
然后你问他，他会说，好吧，如果你在看领带，你就没在看演员的脸。我希望你沉浸在正在发生的事情中，他会说场景里的黑色部分是对的。它们需要再暗50%，因为那样你才能真正进入瞳孔，你知道吗？这一切都是关于内心生活。
He wants to see, which I think is, you know, that's what makes those movies rewatchable and timeless as he there's a lot of respect that people will get it, you know, which fucking yeah, it's also got this, he's also got this, he's got a like a Michael man three quarter shot of this like a handheld that's right behind the actor's ear and it just kind of creeps around a little bit and exposes just one of the eyes and it gets you inside an actor's head like he a character's head. He uses that quite a bit. I love that. Yeah, I don't know if there's a camera invented yet that would be able to reveal any interlife
他想看到，我认为，你知道，这就是让那些电影值得重看且永恒的原因，因为他非常尊重观众能理解这一点，你知道，这真是，是的，他还有这个，他还有这个，他有一个迈克尔·曼式的四分之三镜头，那种手持的，就在演员耳朵后面，它会稍微蠕动一下，只露出其中一只眼睛，它能让你进入演员的头脑，就像角色的头脑。他经常使用那个。我喜欢那个。是啊，我不知道是否已经发明了能揭示任何内心生活的摄像机
on Jason. I don't know. No, just like a fuck like just fucking dad like a dial tone inside. I think you think of like you hear like a wind, like wind going through an old outhouse out in the middle of the desert. That's the sound. Yeah, that's a fall asleep earlyzy. You know, you talked about, you talked about, you talked about driving about fries and stuff so you get the drive.
在杰森身上。我不知道。不，就像一个该死的，就像一个该死的拨号音在里面。我想你想到的是，你听到像风一样的声音，就像风穿过沙漠中间的一个旧厕所。那是那种声音。是啊，那是让人入睡的。你知道，你谈到了，你谈到了，你谈到了开车，关于法拉利之类的，所以你得开车。
So had you ever driven a Ferrari before? No, no, no, no. Never driven a Ferrari. Do you have one now? No, no, no. Do you want one now? Would you ever get one? If it gave me one, sure, yeah. Are you like a motorcycle guy at all?
那你以前开过法拉利吗？不，不，不，不。从来没开过法拉利。你现在有一辆吗？不，不，不。你现在想要一辆吗？你会买一辆吗？如果有人送我一辆，当然，会。你是个摩托车爱好者吗？
I, yeah, I have a couple motorcycles. You do, of course you do. You got children now, I know. I know, I know, but. Yeah, let's get rid of those. Do you guys know this that I had a Ferrari for a few years? Is that right? Yeah, I had a Ferrari.
我，是的，我有几辆摩托车。你当然有。你现在有孩子了，我知道。我知道，我知道，但是。是啊，把那些处理掉吧。你们知道我曾有几年开过法拉利吗？是吗？是啊，我有一辆法拉利。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Is that what you fucking buy you one? It's a long story, but I had that they did. But I had a Ferrari. I was gifted a Ferrari, but it was was one of those old, you know, a Ferrari, the 412. It kind of, it kind of looks like a coupe. Do you remember that car? And it's in the beginning of Rainman, Tom Cruise is driving that when he's going out to Palm Springs and he gets the phone call and he's got a turnaround with the, with the windmills
是啊，是啊，是啊。那是你买的那辆吗？说来话长，但他们确实那样做了。但我有一辆法拉利。我被赠予了一辆法拉利，但那是那种老式的，你知道，法拉利412。它看起来有点像轿跑车。你记得那辆车吗？它在《雨人》的开头，汤姆·克鲁斯开车去棕榈泉时开着它，他接到了电话，他不得不掉头，后面有风车。
in behind. It's a beautiful, beautiful car. You wanted to be Don Johnson and Tom. So you went ahead and you sold that, you sold that Ferrari, the gift to you and you turned a little profit I guess, huh? I ended up selling it because, you know why? Because if you didn't drive it all the time,
那是一辆非常非常漂亮的车。你想成为唐·约翰逊和汤姆。所以你继续卖掉了它，你卖掉了那辆法拉利，别人送给你的，你还赚了一点利润，是吧，哈？我最终卖掉了它，因为，你知道为什么吗？因为如果你不一直开它，
it would sit there and you would constantly have to like, repair shit and that was just the way it was. And I think- What a relatable story. So you just pocketed, what'd you get about 150 grand for it or something like that? No, because I paid so much to keep it. A lot of taxes. It's been such a pleasure. It does seem relatable though.
它就会停在那里，你必须不断地修理它，情况就是这样。我想——真是个有共鸣的故事。所以你只是把钱装进了口袋，你卖了大约15万还是之类的？不，因为我付了太多钱来维护它。交了很多税。真是太愉快了。这看起来确实很有共鸣。
No, by the way, I've known you're mean. Wait, when does Ferrari come out? Christmas day. Christmas time. Christmas time. Just in time. Okay, like a gift from, like a gift from Jesus. Yeah, himself. Adam, I could just ask you, man, I just, I'm just fascinated with him, such a fan
不，顺便说一句，我认识你。等等，法拉利什么时候上映？圣诞节那天。圣诞节期间。圣诞节期间。正好赶上。好吧，就像来自耶稣的礼物。是的，他本人。亚当，我能问你吗，伙计，我只是，我对他很着迷，我是个粉丝
and what you've done, man, and I'm just so happy for you, dude, and you do seem like such a genuinely good guy in, in, in, honestly. Big talent crush, like I said. Yeah, big talent. And you know what, like Jason said, I wanted to say this before, and Jason said, like I said. Yeah, big talent. And you know what Jason said, I wanted to say this before,
还有你所做的一切，伙计，我真的为你感到高兴，伙计，你看起来确实是一个非常真诚的好人。就像我说的，我很欣赏你的才华。是啊，大才华。你知道吗，就像杰森说的，我想在之前说这个，杰森说，就像我说的。是啊，大才华。你知道吗，就像杰森说的，我想在之前说这个，
and Jason said when people run into you, it's not like you're just like some, there's a difference between being a celebrity and being an actor, and you're such an actor. And I mean, that is such a compliment. You're such an artist, hate using that term, but it's true to you, man. And anyway, I just wanted to say that.
杰森说当人们遇到你时，不像你只是某个，名人与演员之间是有区别的，而你是一个真正的演员。我的意思是，那真是个赞美。你是一个艺术家，讨厌用这个词，但对你来说是真的，伙计。总之，我只是想说那个。
I just think that you're... That means a lot. Yeah, man. Thank you a lot. Yeah, man. Thank you. You are amazing, man. I'm so glad that you joined us today. Thank you for doing this. Yeah, no, thank you for having me.
我只是觉得你……那意义重大。是啊，伙计。非常感谢。是啊，伙计。谢谢。你太棒了，伙计。我很高兴你今天加入我们。谢谢你做这些。是啊，不，谢谢你们邀请我。
Yeah, thanks, buddy. Yeah. I'll look you up when I get to Brooklyn. And we'll ask you. He's good, man. He's got a lot of money. He's super good. You're going to love it.
是啊，谢谢，伙计。是啊。我到布鲁克林时会找你的。我们会问你的。他很好，伙计。他很有钱。他超级好。你会喜欢的。
Yeah. Thanks Adam, such a pleasant meeting. Adam Driver, thanks, buddy. Thanks for taking my time. All right. Thank you. Thanks for having me. All right. All right. See you.
是啊。谢谢亚当，很高兴见到你。亚当·德赖弗，谢谢，伙计。谢谢你花时间。好的。谢谢。谢谢你们邀请我。好的。好的。再见。
Bye. Wow. Right? Yeah. JB, I knew you knew him. Yeah, I'm surprised. What didn't come up was some sort of tie into his last name and the Ferrari movie. Right, who's going to do that?
再见。哇。对吧？是啊。JB，我知道你认识他。是啊，我很惊讶。没提到的是关于他的姓氏和法拉利电影之间的某种联系。对吧，谁会做那个？
One of these critics are going to do it, right? Somebody writing a review or something. The driver really drives this driving movie. Who's going to do that? One of these critics are going to do it, right? Somebody writing a review or something. The driver really drives this driving movie, huh? Something like that. I can go ahead. Yeah, well, if they're going to do it, it'll be probably a little bit short. Probably something like that. Yeah. Well, you know, the whole time, anytime you said that word, it was something like that. No, it's something like that. He's really cool. It's wild to meet him. It's really cool. That's how he is.
这些评论家中的一个会做的，对吧？有人写评论之类的。德赖弗（Driver）真的在驾驶（driving）这部驾驶电影。谁会做那个？这些评论家中的一个会做的，对吧？有人写评论之类的。德赖弗真的在驾驶这部驾驶电影，哈？类似那样。我可以继续。是啊，好吧，如果他们要这么做，那可能会有点短。可能类似那样。是啊。好吧，你知道，整个过程中，每当你提到那个词时，就是类似那样。不，是类似那样。他真的很酷。见到他真是太疯狂了。真的很酷。他就是那样。
He is a very, very good dude. Yeah. Yeah. He just, he seems very sort of like he's got like a generous spirit. Like you said, he's an actor. He's an actor. He's an actor. Oh, yeah, he's an actor.
他是一个非常非常好的家伙。是啊。是啊。他只是，他看起来非常，就像他有一种慷慨的精神。就像你说的，他是一个演员。他是一个演员。他是一个演员。哦，是的，他是一个演员。
He's, yeah, he's so calm. He's, yeah, he's excited to have him. He's going to be, he's going to be with us for a long time. He's going to be like, yeah, great actors until we're old and gray. Yeah, for sure. And I just, I don't know. There's something about, I love the fact that, and I know, I don't feel like it did a good job of getting into it of like this.
他，是啊，他太冷静了。他，是啊，很高兴有他。他会，他会和我们在一起很长时间。他会像，是啊，伟大的演员，直到我们变老变白。是啊，肯定的。我只是，我不知道。关于这一点，我喜欢这个事实，我知道，我不觉得我做得很好，没能深入探讨这一点。
The way that he just kept, he applied to July 2017, didn't get in, but then he went into the military, but then he came back to it. And he went, like, he was like, he went to LA and then, it broke down and he fucking went home, but he came back to it. Like he just, he was not going to be, this is what he wanted to do. And he knew he had a gift for it. You don't stop, do you get it? You don't stop.
他一直坚持的方式，他申请了2017年7月，没进去，但他去了军队，但他又回到了这里。他去了，就像，他去了洛杉矶，然后，它崩溃了，他该死的回家了，但他又回到了这里。就像他只是，他不会被，这就是他想做的。他知道他有天赋。你不停下来，直到你得到它？你不停下来。
He's a serious person that also it's got a great sense of humor. It's not really funny. It's really funny. It's really, really funny. I didn't know, I didn't know, first of all, I didn't know he went, it was in the Marine Corps. And that's why I asked him like, First of all, didn't know he went in the Marine Corps. And that's why that's why I asked him like where he did like a Ted talk where he talked about it.
他是一个严肃的人，但也很有幽默感。不是真的好笑。真的很有趣。真的，真的很有趣。我不知道，我不知道，首先，我不知道他去了，他在海军陆战队。这就是为什么我问他，比如，首先，不知道他去了海军陆战队。这就是为什么，这就是为什么我问他，比如他在哪里做的，像TED演讲，他在那里谈论了它。
I saw that. Oh, really? I don't follow all the Ted talks. Yeah. It's it's it's really. You're not up in your. I'm sure he's not the only actor that's been a Marine, but you don't hear about it a lot.
我看到了。哦，真的吗？我不关注所有的TED演讲。是啊。它，它，它真的。你没跟上你的。我相信他不是唯一一个当过海军陆战队员的演员，但你不会经常听到这个。
I mean, you know, that's a lot of. The whole time he was there. That's why I asked him if he was thinking about acting. What's that? Rob Riggle. Rob Riggle. Yeah, I knew. But yeah, you don't hear about a lot.
我是说，你知道，那有很多。他待在那里的整个时间。这就是为什么我问他是否在考虑演戏。什么？罗伯·里格尔。罗伯·里格尔。是啊，我知道。但，是啊，你不会经常听到这个。
So you didn't know he was in the Marines and what else he was in the Marines. And I like what he said about Michael Mann too about, you know, you always buy into it and everything, everything that he, Adam does, I think. Oh, I thought he just parted by your buy. Right there. You said that Adam plays. You also buy into it.
所以你不知道他在海军陆战队，还有他在海军陆战队里还做了什么。我也喜欢他关于迈克尔·曼的说法，关于，你知道，你总是相信它，每一件事，每一件事，亚当做的，我想。哦，我以为他只是分开了你的买。就在那里。你说亚当扮演。你也相信它。
No, no, no, no. Will you guys think? I was going to say, less sloppy and just like easy way out, like you, like as if you're late for a bus. I'm gonna say hearing what he said, those were really words to live. Bye! Bye! Acceptable.
不，不，不，不。你们怎么想？我本来想说，没那么草率，就像容易的退路，就像你，就像你赶不上公交车一样。我要说听到他说的，那些真的是值得活下去的话。再见！再见！可以接受。
We will allow, bye. Bye. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Unjurf.
我们会允许的，再见。再见。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。Smartless是100%有机的，由Bennett Barbaco、Michael Grant Terry和Rob Unjurf手工制作。
If you like Smartless, you can listen early and add free right now by joining Wundri Plus in the Wundri app or on Apple Podcasts. Prime members can listen to add free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wundri.com Slash Survey. What if your partner developed 21 new identities? Or you discovered that your friend who helped you through the darkest times was actually a conniving con artist?
如果你喜欢Smartless，你现在可以通过在Wundri应用程序或Apple Podcasts上加入Wundri Plus来提前收听并免广告。Prime会员可以在Amazon Music上免广告收听。在你离开之前，通过在Wundri.com/Survey填写简短的调查告诉我们关于你自己的信息。如果你的伴侣发展出21个新身份会怎样？或者你发现那个在你最黑暗时期帮助你的朋友实际上是一个狡猾的骗子？
Or what if you began seeing demons everywhere, inhabiting people around you, including your son? What would you do? I'm Whit Missildine, the creator of this is actually happening, a podcast that brings you extraordinary true stories of life-changing events, told by the people who lived them. In our newest season, you'll hear even more intimate first-person accounts of how regular people have overcome remarkable circumstances, like the man who went to jail for 17 years
或者如果你开始到处看到恶魔，占据你周围的人，包括你的儿子，会怎样？你会怎么做？我是Whit Missildine，《这正在发生》（This Is Actually Happening）的创作者，这是一个为你带来改变人生的事件的非凡真实故事的播客，由经历过它们的人讲述。在我们最新的季节里，你将听到更多关于普通人如何克服非凡情况的亲密第一人称叙述，比如那个因为意外射杀试图救他的人而入狱17年的人，
for accidentally shooting the person who tried to save his life, to a close friend of the infamous scam artist Amanda Riley. These haunting accounts sound like Hollywood movies, but I assure you, this is actually happening. Follow this is actually happening on the Wondry app or wherever you get your podcasts, and you can listen to this is actually happening ad-free on Wondry Plus. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
到臭名昭著的骗子阿曼达·莱利的密友。这些令人难忘的叙述听起来像好莱坞电影，但我向你保证，这正在发生。在Wondry应用程序或你获取播客的任何地方关注《这正在发生》，你可以在Wondry Plus上免广告收听《这正在发生》。你 这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。